hey everyone Deo here and in today's
video like I promised we are going over
the entire one punch Man story from the
moment season 2 ended all the way up
until the end of the most recent
complete Arc but let me warn you before
we all do get into this video right here
that this Arc is just pure Insanity from
the start to finish with a constant
battle that never seemingly ends is the
Earth's strongest S-Class heroes are
pitted against the entirety of the
monster Association quickly if you do
want more stuff just like this where I
go over the entirety of a series and
excruciating detail then make sure you
hit the Subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with pushing my content
to a bunch of new amazing people but
anyways enough of that let's get into
the largest solo video and hypers Arc
battle wise I've ever
[Music]
done so starting off in over at the hero
Association s and the other ministers
are bickering over what to do next of
course they think it was King who took
down the massive centipede you know like
right at the end of the second season
nevertheless when it comes to the hero
Hunter himself s insists that go is no
longer human and should be classified as
a dragon level Threat all of a sudden
ninki the rich sugar daddy bursts in
yelling at bang to get the little clone
of his under control along with getting
wagon MBE who's his son in case you know
like any of you forgot that he was
kidnapped by the monster Association
during the later parts of the second
season anyway in turn because of this it
causes second gar the head of the rescue
team and the guy with the goated eye to
assure him that he already is Heroes on
the job trying their best to save his
son later on Sear meets with super Eloy
dark shine or Big D Peg God and the
28-year-old sister that's somehow
smaller than her younger sister
tatsumaki he informs them that child
Emperor is already actively searching
for the monster Association headquarters
in cityz however tataki keeps on
mentioning how the monsters are nothing
and are just having their strength
overestimated making second G inter vene
and actually reveal to them that these
monsters are built slightly differently
as an srank hero like middle Knight has
already gone missing at their hands I
mean you know like throughout the series
so far these srank Heroes have been
built up like they can't be defeated by
anything but as we know these monsters
inside of the pet that they manifest are
built completely differently all of them
sucking on those monster cells has
completely changed the entire game
anyway anyway kamakazi B know and his
just big Atomic Samurai along with his
disciples arrives back at the hunter
Association after searching for the
monster headquarters and has a light
quarrel with the aass hero sweet mark
meanwhile PTY poty prisoner also heads
towards the scene back in child
Emperor's office it's revealed that he's
sweating hard trying his best to find
the dreaded monster Association
headquarters while asking the pestering
nobodies to leave him in peace as he
searches once he's by himself he
immediately contacts booy whose best
known by his hero Alias as middle Knight
only to get instantly nervous when booy
tells him that there's a literal god of
the monsters a complete amalgamation of
beasts and monsters mashed together to
create an Unholy Beast older than all
ages of men man called the monster King
arochi and that he is possibly the real
deal outside and somewhere else Fuki
finds the sarm clan literally having an
acupuncher day and honestly just
enjoying themselves while the world
around them is completely falling apart
she begins screaming at them but the
screeching just absolutely nothing until
saama gets up to find G on his own
accord and also man's you know like
going to go off and get some cabbage
anyway meanwhile ninki appoints his own
measly Rescue Team to try and get his
son back giving them his top Tier gear
that he paid for with his money and
sending them to the monster
association's location early over
somewhere else while the drama continues
G wakes up inside of the monster
Association all beat up and bruised
until he stumbles outside to find a
whole Carnival of monsters by the way
guess who like all the monsters are
going ham on well it's the ranky said
Rescue Team who's already caught Plus on
top of them being just utterly weak
they're also cows who are just crying
for their lives with all of the monsters
gathered around them their Roars Echo
out and they scream wanting to be feared
impatient one of them launches at at the
group only to be sliced in half like a
literal PB andj sandwich by the Ripper
who then instantly starts screaming out
his own feelings on how he wants to
torture each and every one of the
soldiers personally yet just like before
him he is interrupted by Super S the
lovely lady herself who's adamant about
making them her dirty little whipped
slaves nevertheless G who's kind of just
been sneaking around is soon spotted and
brought to the spotlight standing there
he finally sees the dreaded demon oroi
the massive and when I say massive I
mean it like this guy has literally the
size of a few buildings both Orochi and
his slimy number one Goro offer him a
place in the monster Association even
going as far as to offer him a spot
among the strongest tier of monsters
inside of his Association however to be
given this opportunity he has to bring
the head of a hero to prove his loyalty
first taking all of this in G decides to
head out to do more hero hunting and as
he walks away yo sends both Ripper and
Bug God to tail him outside and in the
city the general masses like have
completely and utterly lost it and a
cult of monster worshippers are already
making the rounds grabbing poor men who
try to retaliate against them as an
offering for the monsters feeling a bit
of pity for these idiots giving up so
quickly G who's like now outside the
monster Association just casually flicks
them all off before heading into a diner
and ordering the massive super sized set
meal complete with thick steak and extra
rice then also on top of that as the
lovely female waiter goes to leave he
orders everything else and the meet menu
and knowing to G though the bald man
himself s Hammer is actually feasting at
the same place and currently losing his
mind when he realizes that he's left his
wallet at home as the Bold hero oozes
with sweat and wonders how he's going to
pay for the meal the volumptuous Queen
herself Fuki sits down before him
blabbering as per usual seeing the
perfect moment to enact his plan sa must
slides his plate over to Fuki and as she
munches down on the chips she notices
his devious smile while she sits there
thinking to herself B is probably happy
to work for her a shriek of panic rings
out calling after a dying Dasher who's
just sprinted off without pain of course
playing the hero to save his own behind
in the situation sa also rushes off
Plastering the Bell onto Fuki and the
proess which is like kind of funny as
like FBO here at this moment is still
super adant that s actually wants to
join her little old group and obviously
you know he doesn't anyway nevertheless
after G had scrambled out of the
restaurant and made his way down the
road he notices a group of young bullies
picking on the same tario kid from
earlier on having gone over and
dispelled the bullies the kid starts a
petty shower and recounting how G's
actually a good guy being attacked
unfairly by all of the heroes around him
annoyed because he obviously thinks he's
a monster at this point G considers
going demon mode and flicking the kid
away to prove it however our Bard King
who's been chasing him from back at the
restaurant finally catches up and
arrives yet it ain't exactly what you
think and due to the fact that Sait also
had no money and needed to ditch the
diner he hilariously lets him off on the
thievery just this once and forgives him
for it all without go ever turning his
way revealing who he actually is to
saama as the CATE B he then goes to
leave and now annoyed G turns and makes
the dire mistake of fully confronting
him obviously car at this point in the
series and probably still for a while
like after this doesn't actually have a
clue who s is which is evident by the
fact that tiio who's with him points out
that he's not even inside the hero
directory now walking towards the D Sor
who hasn't even turned around yet G
thinks on how it's not the worst that
the monster Association has looked down
on him but now here has some noname
snotty Brett taking pity on him for
being too poor to pay for his meals re
affirming that he isn't with the monster
Association in his head but will take
their offer either way he proceeds to
walk up on S Hammer ready to blow him
down with one strike grabbing the bal's
shoulder the ever revolving garab
appears to take out s Hammer with one
quick rage filled strike however before
he even has time to react saer
instinctively throws a backand under the
premise that he can't fight as he's
wanted man and can't be seen with him
waking up in a panic Terio asks him if
he's okay while telling him that the B
was freaking out over the fact that he
may have just murdered a random him
before he quickly ran off emerging from
the Shadows behind him the bug God and
Ripper who had been watching all this
time decide that he isn't worthy to be
called a monster or receive the powers
after seeing him get defeated so easily
by a random no-named caped Bal Royal
Ripper reveals that guro had sent him
and bug go to follow and monitor go
after observing his behavior they now
have doubts about G's true intent
questioning whether he's a true monster
or not g then proceeds to revoke Royal
Ripper to little use and the letter then
demands former to kill tario G then
inquires about the reasoning behind the
request to which bug God replies that
one must leave behind what makes them
human in order to qualify as a monster
Royal repper reaffirms the statement and
continues adding the fact that g might
not be the best candidate after being
defeated by site Hummer G then proceeds
to tell Tero to go home but he was
unable to do so because of the fear cing
over the young child due to this tiio is
berated by Caro who then slaps the hero
catalog out of his hand saying that the
boy needs to get stronger during Times
Like These while doing so Royal Ripper
attacks tario but the attack is quickly
stopped by go who hoisted Royal Ripper
up into the air by his blades and
swiftly delivered a kick to the
opponent's abdomen Royal Ripper then
flies up into the air as a result of
this but is quick to get back to his
feet by thrusting his blades onto the
ground and performing a su assault with
the two blades acting as an anchoring
point the move severely disfigures his
arms but Royal Ripper restores his limbs
back to the original state by twisting
them back G then yells at tiio telling
him to run with boy comping as he is
seen dashing away as he is doing so
though Royal Ripper announces G to be an
enemy and G then assumes The Stance as
the two monsters begin charging at him
at top of roof zombie man is observing a
takoyaki shop suspecting it to be the
new front for the house of evolution
upon entering he encounters armed
gorilla who assumes zombie man to be a
customer the hero introduces himself but
is surprised by armed gorilla after he
reveals that the house of revolution has
ceased to exist zombie man then meets up
with Dr Gus who then goes on to mention
the fact that he finally remembers
zombie man as the successful Immortal
specimen that escaped and destroyed his
facility immediately after zombie man
threatens Dr genius with a large ex and
asks him why the house of evolution was
destroyed stating that the facility
could always be rebuilt as long as genus
is alive the scientist responds by
giving an account of his events with
scama who according to genus had removed
his limiter and possesses greater power
than anything artificial thus disproving
his research he then goes on to expand
the concept of the limit
explaining that every single being has a
limit on how much they can develop
because too much power can potentially
create mindless rampaging monsters as
such God created the limit to restrict
everyone's abilities thus ensuring their
survival and mental Integrity zombie man
then raises the question of whether the
person who removed his limiter did so
without any cost this is quickly refuted
though with genius stating that the
individual paid for his immense Power by
losing his hair and having to Bear the
overwhelming sense of Detachment from
society ZB man responds by saying that
those who possess immense power without
becoming a monster are called Heroes Jus
then goes on to explain to him the
relationship between monsters Heroes and
their removal of limited according to
him humans become monsters due to
internal factors bad habits mental
abnormalities or frustrations as well as
external pollutants or like chemicals in
the atmosphere and as such are different
from those who remove their limit her
monsters such as sea folk appearing in J
City or the dark meta thieves are simply
sentient beings that are host to humans
as for Heroes Jus states that they
already possess potential at Birth and
manage to develop their potential
through extensive efforts others could
achieve great Powers through artificial
means such as mechanization
experimentation or born with great
Powers however saitom is an exception
due to the fact that he is an ordinary
person with no unique potential
whatsoever but still somehow managed to
remove the barrier for growth simply
through sheer force of well it is for
this reason that Jus relinquished his
own ambition saying that they are now
laugh ball zomie man lastly requests an
explanation for the takayaki stand to
which genius explains that he discovered
a method to produce unlimited octopus
tentacles back over as the two monsters
charged at G the hero Hunter managed to
deliver a powerful punch towards the
bug's torso unfortunately this injures
his own hand in the process Royal Ripper
then follows up and performs a chain of
frenzy slashes aimed at G but they're
all dodged or Afflicted as Garett was
busy with royal Ripper's chain of
attacks bot approaches him from behind
but his bomb Ed with a flurry of
deflected slashes originating from Royal
repair the monster is underturned by
this as he quickly pounds go into the
ground and then flings him onto some
electrical cables which briefly
electrocutes go go immediately rebounds
himself towards the monsters after this
as they leap towards him as well the
three then eventually enter a stalemates
with go now confident in his abilities
to defeat his opponents it then
transpires though that Terio was
actually captured by the sludge
jellyfish G is briefly distracted by
this occurrence so Royal rer takes the
chance and BR slashes him in the back
and Bug God also subsequently slashes
him in the Torso as well ultimately
being assailed with a series of slashes
that leave him in a pool of blood on the
ground over at the legion's fine
apartment Jos bang bom and King wait
anxiously for him to return When scam
does eventually turn up looking
disheveled they presume that he fought
with go yet syam denies it unaware that
he actually did indeed meet G and
defeated him for the third time however
he is distressed because of the fact
that he lost his wallet and have
forgotten to buy cabbage being a big
brain herself though Fuki then shows up
with a cabbage that sa forgot and also a
Noy that sa made her pay for his meal
meanwhile Jos detects something
approaching fast and sends King to deal
with it there the monster is revealed to
be Dr Casino who came in his mechanical
suit to check up on Jos Dr Casino
introduces himself to S and Gifts some
high quality meat for his hot pot s
instructs Jos to prepare the hot pot
meal before realizing that he would
actually have to share with all of the
other visitors mean meanwhile in the
monster Association Royal Ripper and Bug
God tried to explain Go's death to gu
Goro putting the blame on the hero
Hunter himself guguru sees through their
Antics but spares them from their
punishment instead telling them to take
things seriously as the hero Association
could attack in a few hours many members
of the monster Association are seen
preparing nearby socializing or
otherwise loitering as they wait around
for the battle ahead over in the cells
tario G's only fan is put into the same
cell as the hostage wagon m wagma is
confident that his Rich status means
that the heroes will save him for sure
and snobbishly attempts to make tario
his subordinate hearing them talk sludge
jellyfish attempts to scare him by
mentioning that the executives are
capable of taking on any S-Class Heroes
meanwhile gal wakens in the spot where
he was abandoned and begins to move on
elsewhere at the hero Association
headquarters child Emperor and second go
through the roster of Heroes child
Emperor becomes paranoid after
communicating with booy and he exerts
his influence to remove demon Cyborg and
silver Fang from the mission s despite
his protests on likee not wanting to
remove the two from the group as
instructed to not actually inform them
on the removal over at side's apartment
The Group of Seven are about to eat the
steaming hot spot they rush in with the
Chopsticks all at once throwing food up
into the air with King instantly getting
knocked out although like Dr casino is
fine however nobody notices King knocked
out on the floor Fuki uses her
telekinesis to bring a piece of meat
towards herself but Goos tries to
reclaim it sarm who asks why everyone is
eating his food during the argument that
ensues Dr Casino csos down only for Fuki
to attempt recruiting the old man for
weapons development into her group saama
is annoyed that the meate is already all
gone and soon after finds King sleeping
on the ground not realizing that the tut
was actually knocked out while King's
knocked out at sait's apartment G who's
elsewhere in the city makes his way
towards the Monster association's
Hideout and as per usual is caught on
guo's Psychic radar guo who obviously
thought he was dead orders the other
monsters to go and grab a hold of the
Intruder allowing them to help
themselves to a little bit of before
battle Feast to get themselves pumped up
in their upcoming struggle back with the
main group the hero Association is about
to deploy the remaining S-Class Heroes
to deal with the monsters without
Watchdog man blast and Metal Knight
being an attendance and without Jos and
bang as their whereabouts is currently
unknown tatsumaki threatens second gar
with getting violent if Fuki ever gets
involved in this conflict not wanting to
put her In Harm's Way Every hero from
C-Class to a class who's available will
will be sent to deal with the monster
association's forces above ground while
the S-Class Heroes will only deal with
the dragon level ones above and inside
of the monster association's base back
in the base gal breaks into the facility
just in time to save Tero from roral
Ripper despite being stabbed in the gut
by the monster G simply punches r r his
head straight off with one blow killing
him in the process before using
Whirlwind iron cutting first to shred
the rest of the monster to complete
pieces he andario then make their escape
only to then encounter two monsters who
are obviously quickly dispatched by go
the hero Hunter then devours one of the
limbs of the monsters to replenish
himself before proceeding with tario as
they make through Escape tario tells him
that there is another child that is in
need of rescuing but obviously that's
not G's concern and he didn't actually
come here to save tario either however
before the two can continue on their
escape they're confronted by overgrown
Rover quickly realizing that the dog
like actually won't harm them if they
step quietly back without making noise G
swiftly makes his escape with triio not
alluding the monolith of a dog only to
instantly run into the monsters
showerhead rat and unihorn and honestly
where are these like weird ass monsters
even originating from at the moment like
I I know but still anyways G who
literally can't be bothered with his
subpar monsters mess a hole straight
through the pathetic sh head kicking the
neurod Divergent battle off showerhead
shoots at go with a burst of boiling
water with threat throwing the unihorn
monster at go who ends up Landing
directly behind him however like
remember how G was literally just
gapping it from the dimensional dog who
navigated totally off sound well a
monstrous growl soon vibrates through
the corridor followed by a gigantic heat
blast that completely fries the three
pathetic monsters leaving G with a quick
moment to escape atario up on the
surface sa chills out taking the shaking
ground for another earthquake before
going back to his reading back down
below go hops around the crumbling
underground while running for his life
and yelling at Tio to hurry up however
the little man just isn't fast enough
and G was forced to take a point blank
life-threatening blow directly from POI
which sends the already beaten and bru
hero Hunter shooting through the
underground floors towards the lower
levels of the association getting back
up after the attack G puts everything he
has into one more move and tries to
blast back the dimensional pup yet he is
quickly demoralized and realizes that he
has no effect on the creature instead
the hero Hunter takes yet another blow
and continues his uncontrollable
destructive path as he once again flies
through multiple levels of the
underground base until he lands on the
floor directly in front of the one and
only guro using his Telekinesis the
monster instantly restrained friend G
however instead of taking him out he
invites the infamous hero Hunter to sit
and talk with him looking down on him he
comments on G's incomplete monster
transformation and explains on how he
desires to elevate go into an even
greater Monster not through physical
powers like G questions but through a
specialized monsterification process guu
continues that in order to accelerate
the growth process the human must
repeatedly experience death over and
over again in order to overwhelm the
body and spirit this is obviously a
delicate balance as the human can easily
succumb to death during the process and
even successful candidates will stagnate
due to their low intelligence the key
ingredient needed in this process is for
the human to experience their very own
personal hell despite all of this
knowhow guguru never managed to create a
monster with a disaster level of dragon
except for one suddenly we then see a
random woman wearing glasses approaching
a silhouetted man she states that the
man has turned his back on humanity and
is going crazy suddenly it skips for
four way moment where this woman looks
up towards the newly created monster
King Orochi guu mentions that go has
qualities greater than Orochi and
through his battle with royal riet and
Bug God go has broken through another
wall of impossible limits the psychic
monster offers go to join forces and
under their guidance together they will
crush the heroes and G will attain the
power to become the strongest monster
alive g p himself though refuses beu
refutes his ignorance stating that he
never had a choice the want to reasserts
G's powerlessness against them by again
reminding him of the binding and his
psychic powers which dwarfy witch
sisters tatsumaki and Fuki nevertheless
though go begins to somehow take a step
as he is getting used to this level of
control seeing this the esper
disciplines go with Force as rock are
throw in at him directly in doing so
though it reveals to g a weakness in the
esper he realizes that guro can only
perform one action at a time and through
this he frees himself from The Binding
go mocks the monsters ability and state
thereby killing the brain behind the
monster Association and will naturally
collapse in on itself afterwards however
out of nowhere aochi suddenly intervenes
grabbing G and pulling him down to eye
level with himself around the two of
them the stage suddenly reconstructs and
after a little bit of pting from guo go
begins to do battle against the monster
King Orochi Orochi FS his horns at the
hero Hunter pissing go and leaving
invisible round hole in his abdomen as
the attacks continuously keep coming go
manages to defend himself while using
the water stream Rock smashing fist
techniques and continuously staying on
the Move killing random monsters as he
does so then leaping at the head of the
demon himself mouths within mouths
randomly become morphing into one large
jaw that almost bites down on G
continuing with his ever expanding
arsenal of attacks Orochi transforms
into multiple serpent-like banss they
seem to be a mixture of hydras and
Tyrannosaurus Rex's heads the multiple
reptilian heads then far superheated
flame blast directly at go incinerating
the entire stage and the pro Rus holding
an amalgamation of monsters down like an
arm a large fist forms from the snake
appendices which he then uses to smack
down directly against G again sending
him into a nearby wall yuru calls for G
to give up but he refuses bragging about
his status as a genius combatant he
acknowledges orochi's strength but
claims that he is missing the Primal
Terror that makes him a true monster G
utilizes water stream Rock smashing Fist
and shifts into his fighting stance much
to his surprise arochi copies his stance
and guguru informs him that aochi 2 is a
genius in the same way as go having
managed to adopt his style as they
fought against each other as the fight
renews this time the dragon appendages
all utilize water stream Rock smashing
Fist and Pummel G back sending a flying
into the same wall he was previously
just sent into two with him laying there
seemingly defeated euru comments on G's
lack of blood lust which is commonly
found in Monsters despite his intense
wish to become one as such yurugu plans
to thoroughly brainwash him into another
Ace of the monster Association above him
though scammer who's still annoyed about
the rumbling locks down a manhole where
is certain he heard the noises come from
over at the hero Association the S-Class
hero sit in a meeting for the upcoming
mega battle against the strongest
monsters inside of City Z suddenly the
aass rank one hero sweet mask rolls in
like he owns the place and starts
complaining going on about how he's
quite offended after hearing that he's
not assigned with the S-Class Heroes
child Emperor desperately tries to
explain to amay that the a Class Heroes
will stay above ground and play cleanup
dirty on any monsters escaping from the
base annoyed with the idea of just being
used as a backup though a my mask retort
to mocking the various S-Class Heroes
for just being a bunch of money hungry
Fame dwellers angering everyone in the
room turning the relatively chill
atmosphere into a complete standoff
between the Earth's strongest morons
somehow though King who's just arrived
walks in causing the extremely intense
atmosphere to end and distracting sweet
Mas from the drama that he had just
created meanwhile the hero Hunter team
Leaders sing and such arrive at the
headquarters before the a class Heroes
there after silverfang asks to leave
he's somewhat excused by search but it's
enough of the suit to think that both
silverfang and Jos are untrustworthy
luckily for them though King's losing
his absolute mind realizing that his
moments from having his true identity as
a fraud exposed he quickly DTS away and
tries to hide but it's instantly caught
by the old dog curious as to why the
rank St hero would be losing his mind in
the situation Ben questions him which
results in King actually spilling all of
the info on how he's a complete coward
and will die if he goes out on this
Mission thinking of the spot bang
immediately decides to join him covertly
with saitama to assure his safety after
leaving and heading back to City Z they
find Fuki and Jos already chilling out
at saitama's house getting ready for
their own unofficial Invasion yet before
they can go anywhere they need the Bal
man himself to get back who if you
remember already got distracted and
finally decided to check out what was
going on underneath his own property
with everyone else not wanting to wait
any longer for sarm the group actually
comes to a decision everyone will hit
out while Jos will stay back and wait
for a sensei however unknown to the
whole team saitama is already deep
inside of the sewer system in search of
that painfully annoying rumbling sound
moving forward the hero Strike Team
finally arrives at the ghost town of
City Z led by the Lumin jigan a variety
of numerous beans begin surfacing from
the ground below and surrounding the
hero Strike Team evil eye mocks the hero
Strike Team due to their lack of numbers
and child Emperor Tellies the number of
monsters to be over 150 that are
surrounding them now tataki disregards
the numbers while putty puty prisoner
and urges his boys to stay behind him
evil ey then telekinetically lifts
several buildings and explains his
origins of being a weak psychic who was
embedded with eyes from Monsters killed
by Heroes before dropping the buildings
on all of the heroes tataki responds
though by creating a barrier protecting
the Strike Team but it also leaves them
to deal with the falling debris that
come straight after puty puty prisoner
and super ELO dark shine ultimately save
Shadow ring narciss stoic gear spur
green and food betler for tooshi from
the falling deberes above him as tataki
steps out to confront the monsters
around them evil eye which is just like
jagan's other monster Name by the way
declares that it will gouge out the eyes
of the little esper and her younger
sister as an experiment which angers
tatsumaki unless you anger through the
destructive force tatsumaki uses her
signature tornado move lifting Jun into
the air with their esper abilities while
at the same time below the rest of the
monsters attack and the supporting
Heroes all show off their skill for the
most part the heroes actually find them
easy mate and beat them all back showing
off their respective skills sweet Mark's
comments on F the potential and fleshy
flesh asked Shadow ring where she leared
H and Jitsu to what she explains that
she actually leared it from another
place and not the one where fleshy flesh
learned his super Eli dark shine Praises
mizuki's muscles while he effectively
blows up some monsters himself even the
absolute G is getting in on the beat
down and shooting laser beams from his
metallic eye while revealing his past
desire to become a hero although like he
failed his hero examination more
monsters suddenly show up but rhan
wrestler barges his way through once a
tiger level threat Ryan wrestler has
trained enough and now can be rated as a
demon level threat according to guo the
supporting Heroes try to engage him but
Rhino wrestler easily slops all of their
attacks while also racing their
effectiveness at the same time from
above Atomic Samurai who's honestly just
had enough of watching the a Class
Heroes struggle against him drops in
telling everyone to leave while also
slashing so quickly that the Rhino
wrestler doesn't even notice he's been
cut until it's far too late however just
before he did tie seeing this random
drop down asly infuriates Rhino who goes
to attack but instinctively rates Atomic
Samurai as 100 points before he explodes
from the hero's attack other East Class
Heroes then easily Wipe Out the
remaining filth with tataki dropping
down the remains of jagan puty puty
prisoner is surprised that evil eye
managed to retain his form but hearing
this tataki wipes out the monster until
nothing is left at all above Yu's spy
drone is cut in two by child Emperor yet
the alien states that he has already
seen enough of the battle to gauge this
strength although he would have
preferred to see King in
action the rest of the S-Class Heroes
take their Ro Roots into the monster
association with atomic Samurai's
disciples following him flashy flesh
goes over the information on the
transmitter before he suddenly accosted
by a group of weak monsters obviously he
absolutely dunks on those poor fools
only to come face to face with Gil wind
and hellfire flame soon after now these
two floint boys who are also extremely
fast compliment flashy flash on a speed
as he unsuccessfully tries to kill them
they continue their battle with healthy
flame using a steel wires like a net
almost turning flashy flash into a bunch
of ninjas shashimi but flashy somehow
manages to escape cutting the whole wall
causing the two to flip the floor and
take the Clash to an underground sitting
all the wild fleshy flesh tries his best
to determine who hired them gwin
jokingly asks him if it could be ABAB
Boza the king of organ traders who hired
him but fleshy flesh denies the idea
saying that he had already killed him on
top of that fleshy states that he had
already killed Harold the drug kingpen
Hearts collector bagura Phantom Chief
chimusa the Invincible pirate Captain
devil storm and the higher-ups of the
Coalition of Assassins
while hearing this gwin remains
uninjured and the trio continue their
battle they might flashy saying that
they're at their peak of their physical
strength now until fleshy flesh adits
their supersonic battle dashes in and
lightly grazes both of their cheeks
however while doing this he notices that
there's more to these demon level
monsters and beckons them to unleash
their true form the jeer then morph into
their monster forms revealing to be
Dragon Level Threats and instantly Vault
towards flashy Flash in an attempt to
try and kill him striking against
Flash's blade Gail whips out his Blazer
and scattering slash however the much
more experienced flashy Flash beely Blow
easily before pointing his blade at his
enemy and using one of his own moves the
heavy flashy slash to destroy Hellfire
flame sword splitting his blade in two
the impact is so deadly in fact that the
whole Bridge behind them crumbles down
as a result gwind expresses astonishment
at fleshy flesh's technical prowess and
the monster decides to abandon the
battle as ninjas to instead fight using
brute strength and speed the two then
come at flash punching and slashing at
him at the same time with blinding speed
however once fleshy flesh decides to
finally become serious he strikes them
both with a series of SuperSonic karate
kcks enough to uncoordinated them
allowing flashy flash to slice the two
and half with his lethal flashy slash
ending both of their lives with the area
collapsing around and behind him fleshy
flesh decides to leave and try to find
some other people after running for a
moment he arrives at a junction and
decides to use his locator to figure out
his location only to realize that he
sadly lost it during the hate of battle
well walking down a passageway and
monitoring what the other heroes are
doing child Emperor realizes that fleshy
flesh's transmitter seems to have failed
yet before he can think on it any longer
a random monster tries to attack him
only to quickly be shot dead by one of
his robots protecting him he then finds
the remains of a destroyed middle Knight
robot and notes that someone appears to
have attempted to reassemble it and has
disassembled some parts with real
expertise his concerned that there may
be a robotics expert working with the
monster Association and the technology
that was developed to fight against the
monsters may end up being used against
against the heroes themselves he then
decides to try salvaging some of the
information from the remains of the
robot and hopes of finding out where the
hostage wagon m is being held it's
revealed that the robot yields a
detailed map showing where the hostages
held causing child Emperor to get angry
that middle Knight refused to share this
information despite knowing it he calms
himself and unwraps a sweet to eat when
he suddenly notices that octo tank has
been destroyed by Phoenix man who asks
if he was here to play Phoenix man
monologues while standing there about
his role within the monster Association
and his backstory in life before
suddenly attacking child Emperor only to
run hard into an invisible shield as the
monster reels back in pain child impra
Nots that this was a lightweight Shield
he developed and it could even be folded
and wrapped around suedes he then simply
executes Phoenix man with an array of
tools that spring out of his gizzed
backpack running over to the cells he
rescues wagon Mar by guessing the
monsters guarding the hostage cell while
protecting him with a frog themed gas
mask as the jewer are about to leave the
sludge jellyfish oozes his way in and
attempts to crush child Emperor only to
realize that this is unsuccessful as
child Emperor has put up a shield
generated by his umbrella he tries to
cut up the sludge jellyfish with some of
his Gadget which he finds completely
ineffective because of how the jellyfish
is constructed before analyzing and
defeating the monster Suddenly by
dousing it with liquid Fuel and sitting
at a lights honestly the fact that this
dude is like 12 and has the balls to
somehow be able to fire anything is just
like pure inanity plus he has the brain
power to be able to use these Gadgets in
the head of the moment like it just
makes child Emperor one of the B Heroes
out there in my eyes like probably
probably a top five hero within the uh
hero Association in terms of like is he
actually a good person to be honest
dude's straight up insane for his actual
age but anyway as the two then Escape he
notes that something appears to be up
ahead and SS a toy tank out as a scent
tree instantly though the tank is
destroyed and machine God G5 appears
child Emperor attempts to disable the
machine using a high voltage cable and a
jamming signal but G5 defeats his
attempts with ease and continues his
approach after confronting the young J
G5 is able to resist the attacks of
child empress enemy machine disabling
device bugun and swiftly destroys it as
well quickly thinking on the spot on
what to do child Emperor releases his
underdogs then combines them into Mad
Dog robots while G5 is hampered by child
Empress birdline missiles he unleashes
the newly combined Underdog Cerberus to
go over and stall them some more leaving
child Emperor and wamar to escape
running away the duo come across Phoenix
man's shredded body and wear mentions
that he recognizes the costume from a
comedy show called Animal Kingdom the
character had an uncanny ability to
revive itself no matter how many times
it dies as child Emperor Ponders on this
information a flash of light blazes
behind them revealing of course the
Phoenix man who suddenly resurrected
into a new Dragon level threat child
Emperor confronts the monster and uses
his five layers of transparent film to
try and protect himself but it is broken
through by Phoenix man's piercing Bak
attack frustrated at his uselessness
tears flow down his cheeks and child
Emperor is forced to summon his Ultimate
Weapon the mecca Brave giant the Monster
Hideout rumbles as the robotic Parts can
fly in connecting with child Emperor and
smashing into Phoenix man multiple times
not bothered by this though Phoenix man
correctly deduces that the mea has
limitations and simultaneously child
Emperor is confirmed of his Giant's
power limit of 2 minutes and 38 seconds
Phoenix man who's interested in child
Emperor and his costume decides to send
him into the Phoenix space a mental
World connected by those who wear
costumes instead of resuming their
battle Phoenix man then Reveals His
intentions to scout child Emperor
believing that he has the perfect
requirements to become a great costume
monster just like him the monster
explains to the hero how he could never
trust anyone while working as a mascot
and reasons that child Emperor also
desires someone to trust he tries to be
that person offering to create a new
organization built on spiritual unity
and to the child's shock Phoenix man
grabs his hand kneels down and tells the
hero he needs his strength Phoenix man
tries his utmost to monize the child and
guide him on the proper path to become a
costume monster refusing the strength
though the child hero manages to escape
ese the Phoenix bace and slams the
costume monster back with his meas suit
in retaliation the monster activates his
prominence Hawk mode to push Brave
Giants away sending him back crashing
through several pillars Fenix man takes
the fighting stance and tells his
opponent that after seeing his power he
thought the child would change his mind
he then swiftly lends multiple strikes
on Brave giant having changed into his
Phoenix fire Falcon mode to increase his
speed then circling like a shark the
costume chicken begins swirling around
the mea declaring that he would rra off
that armor with ease like a peeling
apple as a means of forcing child
Emperor to grow Beyond his limits
several times and begin his
monsterification trying to fight back
child Emperor unas energy Whip and uses
the 20,000 fold rope skip grinder
technique which acts as an electrical
rope connecting with Phoenix man sending
him crashing into a pillar the two then
fly around before Phoenix man senses FS
out as a visual distraction which Brave
giant manages to block to Phoenix man's
surprise though he suddenly becomes
trapped an electromagnetic webing that
was secretly placed by child Emperor
while flying around earlier now stuck
the hero lands a direct hit on the
immobilized Phoenix somehow though the
costume freak manages to block the punch
and activate his full power the
scorching 10,000 de C prominence hwk
burst which immediately begins to melt
Brave Giants fist child Emperor thinking
quickly and having discovered a water
source below and leashes the output
limiter on his mea which sends the duo
shooting down at top speeds towards the
quickly approaching ground as they
connect with the liquid the impact of
the attack unleashes copious amounts of
water which manages to drag sight armor
who just randomly appeared along with
the child hero along his strong current
child Emperor tries to risc sight Hummer
but Phoenix man manages to reappear
having changed forms into his Phoenix
penguin mode in his new form he can
manipulate ice and uses Phoenix Arctic
Iceberg attack to send the hero crashing
through another floor which just happens
to be the grave of the Subterranean
people taking a moment child Emperor
releases wagon Mar so he can share in
the barrier with scammer whom he
believes to obviously just be an
innocent bystander stuck in this mess
Phoenix man closes in and unleashes an
energy blast directly on child Emperor
the hero tries to retaliate but the
monster notes that it's utterly useless
and decides to bring child Emperor back
into the Phoenix space the monster shows
child Emperor the corpses of the
Subterranean people as an example of
those who fell because their ideals did
not match while monsters with costumes
are different as they share the same
Spirit using the link they share Phoenix
Man reveals some dark truths about the
hero Association to child Emperor like
what exactly the hups have been doing
behind the scenes Phoenix man explains
more of his backstory as a mascot who
was unjustly fired how he kept his
costume on but eventually couldn't
remove it changing him into a monster
child Emperor is shocked and unnerved by
the truth that he was told and nearly
accepts Phoenix man's offer to grab True
Glory with him as a monster but out of
nowhere sa appears saying that becoming
a monster doesn't give one Glory at all
suddenly zombie man comes through in the
communicator updating the child on the
situation and saying how the weaknesses
child Emperor had hypothesized about the
enemy robots were spot on he go on to
thank him on behalf of all of the heroes
and says that he's glad the young
Emperor is here which causes the young
dude to form tears in his eyes zombie
man offers to get milkshakes after the
invasion and asks if everything's okay
with child Emperor who says that
everything is fine and hes zombie man
remains well before resuming his own
battle with Phoenix man turning it up a
notch costume God unleashes rays of
Light which somehow reanimates all of
the corpses of the Subterranean people
as well as galewind and hellfire flame
who all instantaneously attack child
Emperor's Brave giant Phoenix man then
tries to forcibly give child Emperor a
monster cell sing it in through the
cracks of the suit child Emperor spits
out the monster cell and says to Phoenix
man that while his speech was amusing a
hero doesn't just wear a costume and
being a hero comes from within which
goes back to how the dude was previously
fighting without even a suit and just
Gadget alone Phoenix who's obviously
just aggravated by the child's
disrespect and rejection of his peaceful
offer declares that he will be the one
to completely ravage his body as a last
resort child Emperor unleashes his gig
volt smash a large surge of electricity
which also has a side effect happens to
shock galewind and hellfire flame back
to their senses but completely destroys
his Mecca in the process sending him
flying directly towards his enemy seeing
this Fenix man attempts to finish the
child off but in his eyes is sadly
stopped by sight Hummer Phoenix man
mocks child Emperor for abandoning his
suit Before Time ran out though child
Emperor Resorts by saying that the
monster relies too much onor suit
causing the costume freak to crack up
laughing at this claiming that the child
cannot defeat him without Brave Giant
and his attacks before only managed to
scratch his eye suddenly though Phoenix
man begins a mad fit of painful laughter
completely unable to stop standing there
child Emperor reveals that he slid a
tickle tickle bug into the gap between
his face and his Bak he explains that if
he wants the sensation to stop then the
monster has to take off his suit though
still defiant Phoenix man utterly
refuses this idea randomly Phoenix's
body suddenly begins to Glow once more
before a completely in detonates once
the dust finally settles it's showing
that the costume goon has transformed
into a monster chick man an extremely
weak monster the size of a baby cherk
obviously this causes the end of the
battle and makes child Emperor the
confirmed winner saam compliments child
Emperor for his bravery and tenacity
during the battle calling him a good
hero and the young man Returns His
compliment to the Bold hero for his help
throughout it as well quickly though he
remembers who s Arma is and begins to
grow suspicious that Jos is indeed a
traitor since s Arma was so deep inside
of the enemy base
anyway remember how like those two ninja
just got brought back to life well due
to the electric attack correcting their
senses they notice child Emperor and
attempt to take him Hostage to lure
fleshy flashh but sa knocks them both
out before they can even retaliate child
Emperor looks up their information and
discovers that they're both S-Class
criminals he's impressed with the fact
that Sait managed to defeat both of them
only being b class at this point or at
least I think he's b class at this point
he might even be C class still but I
can't actually remember at this point in
the script haven't gone back and watch
the anime for a little while anyway
child emperor offers to take sight armor
to the surface with wagon Mar when out
of nowhere Underdog man mode Cerberus
appears having survived his encounter
with G5 all of them then get on Underdog
man's back and proceed to jump up to the
surface which is just so hack of an
escape tool while soaring through the
air some of roochi dragons appear and
chase them though s easily obliterates
the dragons and wonders if they were
responsible for the noises caused blow's
house as remember like that's literally
what he's trying to solve right now
child Emperor asks Wagar if there were
any other hostages but being a coward
and wanting to get to the surface as
soon as possible he lies saying that
there was no one else skipping away from
the trio somewhere else zombie man
wanders around the monster Laden maze
leaving a trail of shot chopped squished
and squashed monsters in his wake after
a while he makes a crowd of cowardly
monsters that direct them into a room
stating that they won't attack and only
want them to fight something in there
zombie man complies and walks into the
room which the monsters bar off behind
him before him the ominous Betty figure
of a monster called Pure your blood
Cascades down the filthy Menace of a
monster has been chomping down on so
many of its fellow monsters that they've
LED an undy hero to kill him with a
crowd of weaker monsters all cheering
around zombie man and pure blood
engaging their battle with a vicious
monster sanking his teeth into the hero
and Blasting the guy with his own
bullets however we're talking about
zombie man a literal death cheating
demon here like the man doesn't even
know how his own ability works even with
a blowing off head Zombie man still
retaliates back blowing a hole straight
through the monster quickly pure grabs
the nearest be before devouring it and
healing himself so man continues
battling against the monster and after
200 entire deaths which have taken at
least 30 minutes the poor monster who
stood absolutely no chance lays there
exhaustedly dead after the battle he
remarks that he hasn't fought someone as
strong as pure blood for some time and
that it is lift them a little bit tired
before escaping though the hero simply
bends the door's bars around the handle
to lock the room and turns to wipe out
the remaining monsters who had watched
his fight with pure blood after
afterwards he walks out of the room
covered and monsterart then decides to
sit down to heal himself for a bit and
smoke a cigarette while checking his
locator over the communication gear
child Emperor reports that he has
rescued their hostage Wagar and is
bringing them to the surface he also
orders all of the heroes to continue
their assigned missions but warns them
not to venture too far into the monster
Association headquarters in some other
part of the monster maze peod runs into
the great food tub monster and begins to
battle the sound of their battle is
overheard by Ian bushill and ok matachi
who quickly refocus their attention on
the Mind controlled mercenaries and do
is the disciples who constantly live on
that motto of having to live up to
atomics teachings engage do s as she
flows who weip directly at them with an
insane amount of muscled mercenaries
helping her out DS sees the cluster
struggling and lashes out at one of the
disciples however the devilish pretty
boy and my mask drops in blocking the
attack and catching the filthy whip in
one clean grab while telling the others
to move on as it is a bad match up for
them Aon and bushy Joel protest though
unsure of letting sweet fight them by
himself but OK matachi convinces them to
move on and let sweet mask fight in
their place DS tells sweet mask that she
is actually a fan of him and offers to
un-brainwash the slaves in exchange for
just spending time with him s must tells
her that bargaining won't work against
him though and in response the monster
princess immediately attacks by ordering
her slaves to overwhelm the hero
confidently stating that she would make
him her own meanwhile the disciples dash
off to another area discussing what a my
solution could be aan explains that he
believes would simply be planning to
kill all of the brainwashed mercenaries
initially Ian was confused and
disbelieving about sweet mask's true
nature just like the others are
currently but eventually it became
fairly obvious to them that sweet mask's
actions aren't that of a hero but a cold
blooded murderer remembering what he
once did to the surviving dark meta
thieves as the blood hungry sweet mask
attempts to slice the entire squad's
heads with his hand the disciples
returned to the battle by knocking the
brainwashed mercenaries out with
surprise attacks before sweet Mar can
callously murder them however the
surprise attack gives sweet musk a
chance to grab the princess's web and
slam her head into the wall completely
disorientating her standing there amay
displeased that The Swordsman came back
and interfered with his conduct of
Justice however The Swordsman having
figured out sweet's real plan pretend
that they believed that he had sent them
away to merely lower the enemy's guard
knowing sweet Master's suspicion of him
Ian tells his fellow swordsman to go
along with his threatening and
apologizes to him for the
misunderstanding over the manical man's
mind the dude is fully contemplating
whether or not to murder The Swordsman
as well because he believes that they
are now evil since they unhanded helped
the evil accomp before sweet Mas can
fully consider his actions the free
ninki Squad thanks the heroes for saving
them you know obviously it was sweet
mask for that actually save them as he
whacked uh do is into the wall knocking
her out and releasing her control over
them anyway standing in there slightly
confused amay watches the scene in
silence however the monster princess
manages to wrap her league around the
hero's throat and pierces his eye with
her tongue while his guarders down
having thought she hurt the hero do is
is shocked when she sees that the hero's
right eye isn't even actually B bleeding
and instead his eye and face are merely
cracked revealing that he is indeed not
human before dois can reveal who sweet M
truly is to the other Heroes her head is
instantly crushed killing her the freed
mercenaries Rush towards sweet mask and
ask him if he's all right but the hero
claims he's fine having already
regenerated the damage inflicted on him
by the monsters instantly the ninki
squid realized who aay is and start
fanboying over him annoyed with all of
the fanbo sweet decides to entrust the
three Swordsmen were taking them back to
the surface while he remains on the ble
field below so there have been a few
Recons for the like upcoming chapters
here so the float in between some of the
certain parts can get a little bit whack
like I'm assuming here I just haven't
been able to find the Recon chapter but
probably after beginning to hit the exit
with the mercenaries aan Bush drill and
OKO matachi continue battling more
monsters slicing up the ground below
them they descend to a lower floor and
encounter the mysterious being devil
long here okachi is romantically
entranced by the monster's Beauty but
manages to restrain herself instead she
swings her blade producing a killer ear
blade that shoots through the sky
connects him with the monster but to the
three's bewilderment the monster easily
blocks it with's here just then more
strings of here literally start
appearing through the FL from the ground
below almost stabbing okam matachi
however bosiu slices the attacks away
while fighting against this monster the
three are reminded of their Master
atomics wise words to achieve this they
all go beyond the limits of their human
bodies to face this atrocity of a
monster meanwhile Putty Putty prisoner
is engaged in combat with s monsters as
he dust clears we see a glimpse of a
seemingly intact PTY poty prisoner who
was still standing back with the
swordsman Ian OK matachi and bushy J are
sh battered from their battle with the
devil long ha here after having cut
through every single strand of devil l
ha here's locks he collapses commenting
that it was his ailles heel surprised by
the victory the disciples comment that
they wouldn't have won individually and
worried that more monsters of that level
may exist deeper into the monster
headquarters as ion thinks about his
master we jump over to the S-Class
Legion himself cutting down several
monsters when all of a sudden a sword
wielding monster called sword devil
executioner who praises Atomic skills
appears surprised by any kind of monster
that could survive his first slash
Atomic Samurai instantly cuts down his
opponent before the monster knows what
even happened Atomic then asks any
monster around him not did to raise
their hand and G5 remember that like
random Droid child Emperor was fighting
before well he raises his mechanical arm
and says that he analyzed all of atomics
moves and quickly begs a high-speed
sword with the samurai Atomic comments
that the day toys have become
interesting and says that he'd like to
buy one prompting G5 to begin its attack
despite copying Atomic slash with two
swords G5 still easily loses to Atomic
Samurai who slashes his foe into
hundreds of mental pieces while looking
quite disappointed about the robot's
overall durability and performance
however he so notices that he isn't cut
through the core of machine God due to
it being made of an unidentified
material harder than its exterior
suddenly a laser beam appears in the
middle of a dust cloud shooting out
towards his homic but he still comt
deflects it with ease and sends an
ablade of his own back to counter as the
flying slash penetrates the smoke Atomic
realizes that his opponent sealed inside
of the robot has already escaped and
says that he'll have to leave it to the
service team of Heroes meanwhile atomics
disciples once again are having a
conversation with nen's private Squad
the group of mercenaries admit to being
envious of the way the three Swordsmen
can cancel out their own blood lust
during fights and invite them to join
the private military company they
actually work for the disciples will
refuse though because the heroic ity
actually integrates with their training
when bushill asks tonara if they
interested in hero work or swordsmanship
the mercenary leader replies saying that
these things can actually get in the way
of their combat style and explains how
being a mercenary forces people to use
dirty moves like acting scared to
deceive enemies as an example tonara
brings up the fact that the entire team
was actually acting when crying in front
of the monsters however like in reality
we all know for a damn fact that all of
them were crying for real Ian appears to
be impressed by the teamwork of the
squad and finds it important that Heroes
like them follow their example now
jumping over to the absolutely petrified
child tario as he's being chased by
black ear I can't say his name obviously
when suddenly a slash from Atomic
Samurai cuts through stopping the
monster and forcing them to dodge
sticking with the jumping around now we
fly to the surface team of Heroes as
they are seen to spatchy many low level
monsters trying to escape from
underground building berer a demon level
threat shows up and blocks the Striking
heroes team Escape Route on the surface
by causing several buildings around to
collapse with explosives child Emperor's
group finally manages to find the exit
hole but annoyingly the manhole is
blocked by two collapse buildings above
it together sa CH Emperor Underdog man
and wagon M simultaneously push the
manhole in an attempt to open it above
them Singa ask screen to somehow make
another exit for child Emperor to escape
through however he and several other
heroes are amazed when randomly two
calps buildings along with building Boer
are suddenly sent flying into the air
followed by child Emperor then showing
up with wagon M sight armor and Underdog
man not knowing that saam's strength is
actually what allowed them to open the
manhole the other Heroes expressed the
surprise at child Emperor's impressive
capabilities singar then notices saitama
and asks child Emperor about his
identity to which he answers that he
rescued sa too and says that he is a
hero as sigar questions whether or not
saarma was taken hostage saarma responds
saying that he went underground just to
complain about the noises he heard which
greatly Anor SAR who then tells him to
get out of his sight then literally
doing just as the captain say so s
leaves them just to secretly go back
under ground to continue trying to find
the source of the rumbling child Emperor
informs the Striking team Heroes via his
transmitter about wagon my safety which
actually brings the main reason for
their attack on the monster Association
to an end as he finishes speaking zombie
man comes on the Mike and praise His
Child Emperor for a job well done
hearing this the young man is happy that
zombie M responded in that moment amay
responds too saying that he would
continue trying to carry out Justice
inside of the Monster Hideout the next
hero Peg God while digesting something
also notes that nothing is out of the
ordinary with them currently then
finally Atomic Samurai informs them that
he found another child who had been
pursued by a black sticky substance
inside of the monster association's base
much to child Emperor surprise Wagar
acally realizes that it is tario that
Atomic Samurai was talking about and
starts freaking out however before child
Emperor can ask for the location the
transmitter cuts off due to the
realization that there are many other
people trapped inside the young hero
decides to go back and rescue the child
while helping out atomic wenar who's
literally just trying to cover his Rich
behind advises him to not go back and
instead tells the child to let the other
Heroes do their job as he has already
used his Ultimate Weapon while saving
him child Emperor though is still
determined to go back but refuses any
form of help stating that they have to
guard the surface in case anyone tries
to escape Wagar mastering all of his
courage reveals the child Emperor about
the child's identity being tario and
describes his identity to him waganma
apologizes for not telling child Emperor
before as he was too scared and didn't
want him to go back back child Emperor
hearing this simply appreciates the
information and Comforts Wagar shortly
before leaving to rescue tario which is
honestly just pretty nice of the rich
kid for once like like when I was first
reading this I never expected to get a
Redemption Arc from the rich brat but I
guess we did here anyway shooting over
to the Joo Atomic Samurai and black is
began talking to each other black is
gets angry though because Atomic Samurai
attacked him earlier without warning b
maazi gets cocky and says that he had no
business with him causing black is to
morph and form an enormous muscular arm
before asking if he is looking down on
him Tomic samur who like literally just
doesn't care answers whether they yes
before swiftly cutting the arm off and
mentioning that he's fought countless
battles with similar losers who can
transform and shape shift into Giants so
because of that he's used to these type
of opponents randomly though a second
black H then appears from the remnant of
the arm that had just been cut off
causing kamakazi to get annoyed at this
gimmick of his standing there black is
asks Atomic if he still thinks he has a
chance to win noticing that he has a
countless number of black is's merged
into one entity and explains that no
matter how many times he's killed he
will keep on multiplying Atomic Samurai
still greatly underestimating the
monster rapidly cuts his head off while
confidently saying that he just has to
shower the countless number of multiple
forms with countless slashes to win
black ISO continues to mock Atomic
Samurai as the hero still continues to
slash him into countless pieces as those
the pieces then begin to quickly
surround him and regrow into new selves
Atomic Samurai just slashes them again
and again however they just reappear and
even larg numbers jumping on him and
getting slashed into even more pieces
until eventually Atomic Samurai finds
himself face with such a massive amount
of clones that it completely surrounds
him in every single Direction with
overwhelming numbers black is Pummel
Atomic Samurai over and over again
knocking the hero to the ground and
severely injuring him still surrounding
him the monster then begins to taunt
Atomic Samurai telling him that he is
the worst possible match up for the hero
and that there is no possible way Atomic
Samurai could ever win in this bout
laying there and out of options Atomic
Samurai quickly cuts the roof resulting
in the ceiling collapsing in on all of
them the issuing collapse results in
powerful vibrations felt by zombie men
who expresses concern over how the
battle may be going for other Heroes
without warning homeless Emperor who is
legit probably my favorite creation of
affectional character appears behind him
and questions his concerns over the
death of his fellow Heroes before zombie
man has time to react though homeless
Emperor blasts in point blank with a
beam of pure energy it's explained that
his attack here is solely acting as a
means of demonstrating to the hero how
the other heroes are currently being
dealt with thinking that he's merked the
hero he expresses disappointment over
how quickly zombie man was taken out
before going on to State out loud that
he will be the one to kill all 17 of the
S-Class Heroes alone taking them by
surprise though a completely regenerated
zombie man emerges from the smoke and
lunges at him with an axe only to be
counted and shot in the head with a
concentrated blast of energy man I
actually love the battle between these
two just my favorite monster and hero
going absolutely Ham on each other I
can't actually get over how like dope of
a character zombie man truly is those
honestly just a normal human with the
ability that he can regenerate no matter
what happens to him like he doesn't even
have a specific point in his body that
needs to be destroyed he can just
regenerate like it's actually insane
with his opponent disabled homeless
Emperor sters at his body randomly
though a sudden gunshot shoots out from
his upper body homeless Emperor
unflinchingly counters the attack and
blows zombie man away with another
attack SED him crashing into a wall zomb
man quickly regenerates and removes the
pistol stored within his body firing
several shots at his opponents homeless
emperor quickly counters with several
orbs of energy setting them all towards
the hero resulting in a large scale
explosion as the Smoke Clears zombie
mans charred unmoving body stands before
homeless Emperor who compliments his
presumed dead opponent for having lived
up to the expectations of a top hero
strong and unfaltering even in death as
we all know though this man literally
can't die and as he starts to regenerate
he asks homeless Emperor what he is but
mainly as a way to buy time for his body
to regenerate as homeless Emperor is
slightly arrogant he obliges telling him
the story on how his powers originated
he says that until a month ago he was
living at the park as a homeless man he
had lost his job gotten kicked out by
his landlord distanced himself from
Human Society and began living as a
complete hermit he recalls how he was
forced to dance naked in front of his
boss at his new employee welcoming party
only to get fired the very next day for
harassments which is honestly pretty
damn sad when you think about it but
when he stared into the sky that night
the resentment he felt towards his boss
and other such things no longer seemed
to matter to him for to him the Earth
was greater than any man-made structure
and the sky brighter than any man-made
light Humanity was an insignificant
existence on the greater Earth realizing
all of this made him see his home as the
Earth itself which was grander than any
Mansion then one day homeless Emperor
had a life-changing realization he
realized that humans have abandoned the
ecosystem Mother Earth had built up and
thrived under new self-made rules he
thought that everyone was utterly
foolish and that's when he came to
another realization that he was being
walked over by such foolish beings he
could no longer bear the reality of it
which left him borderline on the edge of
life as death was the only way to return
to True coexistence with Mother Earth
right then though an entity homeless
Emperor claims to be God appeared before
him the so-called God agrees with
homeless Emperor's views on humans but
he has no need to die instead granting
him the powers he has now stating that
he should know what to do with it before
disappearing just as quickly as he
entered homeless Empress says that his
power is a divine power granted to him
by God and the reason he was chosen was
because he knew the answer which was
that humans were a harmful existence to
the planet and that the time has come
for him to destroy the entirety of its
existence and civilization to rebuild
the planet's true ecosystem zombie man
who's still trying to stall asks him why
he believed The Entity to be God while
thinking that the situation is bad
because his body hasn't fully finished
recovering homeless Emperor knowing that
zombie men was doubting the existence of
God in his story responds that there is
no need for him to believe in God and
the price of his arrogance will be his
death skipping away from the Divine
homeless man we find that various
monsters find their attacks on Putty
Putty prisoner have no effect regardless
of their variety Putty Putty prisoner
explains to them that embracing the pain
with love allows him to take those hits
and dubs the special power as Angel star
hug realizing this strength wouldn't be
enough the monsters flee only to be
stopped by the demon level monster bqu
who inhales the fleeing monsters
instantly the monster then fires a
variety of attacks at the hero but PTY
putty prisoner Still Remains under turd
the monster mocks him for flinching but
p P prisoner reveals that it was the
creation of his new style of fighting
vibration star Angel the hero then
dashes forward and completely smashes
through bqu ending the monster's life
soon after Putty Putty prisoner hears
the voices of his monsteri boys and
expresses dismay at the inmates
predicaments believing that the inmates
were forced to do the monster
association's bidding he vows to save
them the inmates who absolutely hate the
hero though attempt to explain the
hatred to Putty Putty prisoner but he
continually ignores it Nan then
interjects and says there want a human
becomes a monster they will never turn
back before slashing PTY PTY prisoner
severely injuring him as the rest of the
inmates then dashing on the injured hero
Putty Putty prisoner Stands Strong and
declares that as long as the heart is
human then they will always be his boys
noticing that his body is covered with
hair Putty Putty prisoner uses it as a
shield and dubs it Angel star Bristol
armor Nan disturbed by Putty Putty
prisoner's strange personality decides
to leave him to the other kedr and
escapes through a narrow crack the craze
prisoner though gives chase after
thinking about been new technique called
Angel star craw but accidentally crushes
his fellow inmates in the debris killing
almost all of them seeing all of his
boys Fallen before him he loses his
armored hair and accepts their sacrifice
by avenging their lives and taking out
the nean cat elsewhere a monster watches
in horror as Peg God devours his monster
comrades after mistakenly thinking that
the hero would have been a good feed for
them pigo notices the other monster
watching and grabs him putting it into
his mouth as it screams desperately for
its life gums another monster then
sneaks up from behind Peg God and
swallows the hero initially Pig God
struggles to escape but eventually gums
is forced to spit him out leaving the
two to engage in a battle of the beasts
somewhere else inside of the monster
association's base super Eloy darkshine
encounters bug God and was initially
discouraged by bug God's boasts but
after attacking the monster is let down
by the dude's weak strength super hello
dark shine tells the monster that along
with King and tatsumaki he is one of the
three Heroes that you must never anchor
back over with the swordsman and The
Mercenaries as they try to sneak past
some enemies one of the monsters asks
for the password and not knowing the
answer both the heroes and mercenaries
begin attacking the monsters one of the
monsters manages to escape and using his
abilities is able to open a vault
tracking the escaped monster the heroes
and the mercenaries are able to find the
same vaults after opening it it's
revealed that it contains the infamous
evil natural water monster and mad Dr
fish Master Joe starts explaining what
the evil natural water is and why it's
kept in a tank the monster then gets
gets shot several times in the B by
tonara but somehow it still manages to
push the lever and opens the tank that
is containing the evil natural water
monster instantly Master Joe gets eaten
alive by m Dr fish while the other
heroes are stalled fighting against the
water monster the disciples in the
mercenaries Retreat and try to close the
vault door but evil natural water
monster manages to get out of the Vault
just before they lock the door once
Escaping The Monster Fires two massive
jet streams at Ian and the mercenaries
an attack so powerful that it is able to
put a hole in Ian steel sword but
they're just able to dodge and
Counterattack they manag to get behind a
wall to protect themselves and once they
can attack tonara aims for the Monster's
eyes instead as it seems to be the only
solid part to him the kadre then senses
that tangara is trying to harm it and
counterattacks with a high-speed jet
stream that shoots a hole through the
poor mercenary's chest Bush drill tries
to help the mercenary but the monster
fire several water jets at the hero
stopping them from getting too close
tonara though who's built slightly
differently is able to save bushy Jill
by pushing him out of the attack yet he
unfortunately is modly wounded by the
monster's deadly water blasts having had
his life already saved BOS is left
utterly speechless after what just
happened an and okam matachi then bring
tangara to a safe place while the older
Samurai uses his attacks to block the
monster's path once catching back up
with the group bosel quickly heads over
to quickly talk to tonara while he is
still alive as the evil natural water
smashes at the samurai defenses tongar
tells the three swordsman his name and
they all do the same he then advises
them to escape while they still can and
he'll stay back to hold off the monster
as much as he can as the three end up
running away tonara is left alone
thinking that he is truly an idiot all
the while the evil natural water monster
who hasn't stopped his attacks on their
defenses bursts through the wall with
the May Dr fish accompanying him finally
we skip back over to the Bal King sight
Hammer literally dunking on a poor
monster as he moves forward leaving the
bodies of other monsters behind him
overgrown Rover or Pochi confronts him
saama who's so chill about like
absolutely everything simply gives a
bone to Rover however the hero is
violently attacked by the monster with
multiple energy blasts that are so
powerful they destroy a large portion of
the monster Association base CIT who's
absolutely unharmed simply jumps from
the explosions and punches Rover with
enough Force to shake the entire monster
Association headquarters the other
monsters and heroes sense the force of
the punch and even up on the surface an
even larger earthquake happens shaking
up the area leaving the surface hero
team absolutely clueless to what just
happened below them close enough to have
seen H defeat Rover with one punch nean
sneaks up behind him and uses his super
feline retribution attack against him
but the hero isn't affected at all
instead the cat monster ends up running
away out of fear for the Beast of a
human that he just tried to attack deep
down in the base below everything guo is
sh Seated on his throne thinking about
the Battle situation when all of a
sudden tatsumaki appears at the
monster's side asking if he is worried
about the cadr is being wiped out
curiously bossy terrible tornado then
asks kiriro if he is the boss but then
the monster just welcomes the hero to
the base stating that she is someone
they must take care of personally the
monster then introduces himself to
tataki explaining his position as the
military adviser of the monster
Association and statistically tells the
female isper to drop dead as he suddenly
uses his psychic powers to Pelt and
Surround tataki with several large
Boulders as the monster surrounds tataki
with his rocks he attempts to compact
them all into a small sphere and crushed
her to Mari but the female isper
effortlessly breaks free before
belittling gugo for his week psychic
abilities in retaliation the es seen
several rocks flying at guro who barely
manages to put up a psychic barrier in
time although tataki does manage to bake
through the psychic barrier and take out
some of the monster's arm in the process
seeing that he's in danger the monster
decides to use its maximum power and
fight with its true form as he unleashes
the full extent of his power his body
increases several times in size and
several eyes begin to pop up all over
his monster body the monster proceeds to
use his psychic powers to surround T
Tamaki with high gravity waves then
sadistically remarks that he will turn
the esper into a dried Pon which
honestly I didn't have a clue what the
hell this fruit was I literally had to
Google it to find out and it's some
fruit from Asia just looking at it I'm
assuming because I've never seen it
before over in oceanana anyways as you
all probably expected though the number
two hero is practically unaffected
mockingly saying that the gravity waves
will loosen any stiff shoulders she had
gotten from switching to a new pillow
opposing her guo is utterly helpless as
tataki goes on the offensive and rips
off all of his limbs causing the monster
to scream out in pain after his body is
ripped apart the destroyed moner lament
on how much he had underr rested tou
Mar's abilities until fighting her face
to face lying there he finally admits
the tatsumaki but also says that the
esper was particularly cruel to him in
her final moments tatsumaki though isn't
exactly stupid even though she looks
eight she actually knows the truth on
that she had only fought a mere puppet
being controlled by the real psychic
below her the planet strongest isper
confidently says that she will pull his
real body out hearing this the monster
is left shocked that tataki was able to
see through him but states that fing her
was premature as now she will have to
deal with the monster King left with no
other option after being turned into a
monster pancake the beaten esper calls
out to Orochi to save him yet confusedly
the Dy monster wonders why Orochi isn't
coming to assist him for he managed to
obtain absolute control over him for
years of brainwashing during his
transformation as a monster tataki
suggests that Orochi is engaged with one
of the S-Class Heroes who while knowing
nearly as power as her are still quite
strong according to her the monster
Ponders this possibility and is
frightened at the thought of a hero
strong enough to occupy a roach
powerless and alone hero starts to Big
for his life unbeknownst to him Orochi
actually took notice of s Arma being
able to defeat overgrown Rover and says
he does not know how sa managed to get
in but he can tell that the human is not
useless trash and cannot be ignored
finally this is the first major I guess
you could say Battle of the monster
Association Ark as we have scammer
versus Orochi Orochi after having found
scammer starts the fight by attacking
him with four dragon heads only for them
to be quickly destroyed by the hero
while Orochi expresses his surprise sa
informs him that he actually loves right
above where they stand and just wants to
complain about the noises Orochi has
been causing as a roochi begins feeling
a mysterious pressure emanating from
sight armor overgrown Rover awakens from
being punched into submission earlier a
roochi standing there then Witnesses
overgrown Rover run away from Sama out
of fear upon seeing him and seeing this
asks him if he had done something to the
dog SAA simply responds though that he
had just given Rover a smash due to its
bad behavior with his good sense of
perceiving things Orochi manages to
figure out that Sait is the one who
defeated goketsu and the Elder centipede
further realizing that the rumors about
the ghost town horror weren't referring
to any other monsters but saitama
himself now realizing that the hero's
strength is far beyond anyone he has
encountered before and delighting that
he has finally met someone like him
Orochi takes off his mask and leads saam
to deep underground where a mysterious
Shrine is located after arriving at the
place where the surrounding areas are
flooded with lava Orosi explains to him
that he had discovered a tablet which
depicted him and stated that a worthy
sacrifice was needed in order to
resurrect God leading him to believe
that it was referring to him as a God he
then claims that saam is going to be a
sacrifice for his resurrection and
offers him an allout fight however in
typical fashion Orochi realizes that sa
hasn't even paid attention to what he
was saying as the hero is just trying to
adjust to the environmental changes
around him like Tunas literally
submerging himself in the lava just
chilling out after being confused by
saam's very casual Behavior he decides
to use his full power and intends to
quickly finish the fight by pulling up
energy directly from the Earth's core
and dragging it into his body as a
roochi begins to Source energy from the
core of the Earth itself it causes a
massive worldwide earthquake which is
noticeable by seemingly everyone on the
planet after gathering enough energy in
his eyes to take out sight Hummer Orochi
unleashes has got fire Cannon a
massively powerful energy attack
directed at saama in an attempt to
eliminate the hero in response though
our B King simply meets the attack using
a serious move of his own his prolific
serious squirt gun which completely
cancels out aoi's guy Cannon leaving him
utterly shocked after the first Clash
comes to an end immediately after Sait
jumps towards the monster King and blows
him apart with a single punch ending
their entire battle which is like of
course of course it happened that
quickly having defeated a roochi with a
single punch sa expresses his gratitude
to the monster King for having given him
a new bathing area before leaving arochi
who slowly beginning to fade away
notices that the place is beginning to
crumble with what's left he then crawls
up to the mysterious Shrine in an
attempt to protect it from being
destroyed yet right as he comes before
the ancient table more Stone breaks away
revealing an image of God appearing in
the wall which was completely unseen by
a roochi beforehand since in that aochi
had been defeated guo has all messed up
send out one of his eyes as a scout but
only finds the remains of the monster
King King who coincidentally appears at
the scene is seen by the monster's eye
after which he runs and falls into an
even lower part of the base having not
seen Sarma the eye is randomly destroyed
by the Baldi making guro mistake the
destroyer of aochi for King skipping
away from the strongest beans in this
series so far we find that PTY PTY
prisoner has continued his search for
Nan by swinging through the underground
walls of the monster Association base he
ends up in a small chamber filled with a
torture equipment and notices go
actually chained to the wall seemingly
unconscious not recognizing go as the
infamous hero Hunter poty poty prisoner
thanks he is simply another human
hostage and moves to release him
introducing himself as an S-Class hero
however just as potty recognizes G's
face from the wanted poster G awakens
and breaks the chain before swiftly
pummeling the hero with a multitude of
strikes elsewhere saama continues to
wander throughout the monster
Association base as he searches for
someone to talk to about all of the
noise under his apartment his amb Ed by
a mysterious being but swiftly kills it
with one punch before he can get any
information out of it walking around the
next corner he finds fleshy flesh lying
and wait he gauges saitam size and
deduces that he must be a monster so he
dashes around the corner and slashes at
his Target however saam easily Dodges
fleshy flesh is shocked but actually
recognizes S as the b-class hero who
wants accompany Jos to an S-Class
meeting in the past flashy performs his
special flashy slash move on sight Arma
who simply catches The Sword in one hand
unamused so accuses fles of being a
monster for attacking him first so he
too quickly gets the situation under
control and clarifies that he is a hero
too fles explains that they are in the
monster association's territory and
tells him he should find shelter flesh
also tells him the existence of the
monster King Orochi exciting s yet like
the dude doesn't even realize that he
actually already fought him earlier and
took him out as they move forward fleshy
flesh gets annoyed by s's presence to
stick around trying to run off at high
speeds to abandon him but is shocked
when the Caped Baldi can easily k keep
up with him as s casually keeps up with
flashy flash in the hor of the rer
association base the S-Class hero is
left absolutely flabbergasted wondering
how in the world sa can keep up with
them so easily as they run sa notices
how he has seen the same monster corpse
in section of the HS again and again he
asks fleshy flesh if he's lost only to
be ignored by the ninja fleshy flesh is
literally like the Zoro of the one punch
universe and to is like literally just
sprinting in a full circle hoping to
find someone new to fight anyways
outside m a class and B Class Heroes are
battling a variety of monsters in an
attempt to keep wagon must safe from the
monster Association as the battle slowly
begins to die down and the monsters are
eventually defeated the heroes they
manage to seal off any possible exits
from the association as they voice that
Victory may be imminent poison notices a
tall catlike creature in the distance he
orders one shotter to fire at the
monster only for the bullet to be
intercepted by Nan's claw and he flicked
back at the sniper wounding his head Nan
voices his Joy at coming across a weak
group of of Heroes after meeting Sarma
and insists they all play with him as
jet nce guy states that they all need to
be cautious Nan suddenly appears in the
center of all of the aass heroes and
slashes out all of them wounding needle
star gear spur and twin tail with the
attack Nan announces that he has a cudr
of the monster Association while
muttering to himself how he has already
LIF it to the shock of the other Heroes
seeing that the kid may get KET once
more singar orders food battler for
Toshi to take wagan M to safety at the
same time fear the and poison take a
fighting stance as nen who staring
directly at them eily grins stating the
theme of this game is to rip wagon M
Parts while the group watches in
complete horror hearing this Mizuki
takes her midle transforms it into a
discus and prepares to launch it at nean
while green restrains the monster with
his vines nean with his great speed
though simply catches the disc with his
teeth and shatters it to the athlete
Hero's shock poison tries to attack
Nan's face but his blade is stopped by
the kaj's eyelid and promptly broken as
well as F and Shadow ring try to attack
the creature Nan slips out of the vines
and shatters their blades instantly then
in a Flash before the heroes could even
register what just happened the Cadre
severely wounds the juo defeating them
as the remaining Heroes then steering
shock at the devastation Nan sees a
terrified wagon M running and wonders
where they could possibly be hidden
seeing the creature staring at him wagon
M orders food B for Toshi to stop eating
and speed up only to be informed that he
must eat to replenish his energy Supply
and move seeing the events unfolding
Mizuki attempts to stop n from pursuing
wagon M and food B for Toshi but the
creature simply strikes at her sending
her flying back through the Air Gear
spur cushions her fo with his newly
awakened psychic powers then uses his
remaining energy to launch an attack at
Nan and a pure rage filled attack he
breaks multiple nearby buildings apart
forms the rubble into sharp projectiles
and throws them directly at the monster
burying it in a Cascade of jagged Tetris
blocks as we know though with the espers
in this universe shed out to good on Mob
this extreme use of his psychic powers
alludes for Bui to someone else was
psychic abilities immediately after the
attack G's helmet breaks due to the over
usage of his technique and he collapses
completely exhausted by the way gper is
also a C-Class hero like an actual crazy
feat by the young esper so I'm sure like
after the battle ends he will Skyrocket
in the rankings if he manages to survive
anyway wagon Mark gloats about the
apparent victory of the heroes however n
who's just built slightly differently
hence the connotation of kadre uses his
Supernatural dexterity to escape the
pile and quickly slashes food B for
Toshi's stomach severely wounding the
hero the monster then tells wagma that
he is disaster level Dragon terrifying
the child so much that he wets his pants
again asan then begins to drag them away
so that everyone can witness it suddenly
a massive highspeed projectile breaks
the monster's hold on foshi and wag Mar
the projectile circles back around and
appears at the hands of Drive Knight
revealing that the S-Class Hero has made
his return wagon Martin food battler for
toi run for safety and the former taunts
the monster's apparent Misfortune of
encountering the S-Class hero as second
guard the team leader watches happily
from a distance with the turn of events
Drive Knight uses his tactical
transformation Mark Chariot and lunges
at Nan and an attempt to take him out as
the hero circles around the monster he
sprays an anesthetic gas in an attempt
to immobilize Nan and immediately
charges ad him with his bike form
somehow the cro manages to dodge through
a crack in the ground however drive not
releases a strong solvent into the
ground that forces nearon back to the
surface once back above ground the hero
launches several missiles at the C tray
watch the monster easily Dodges then
retaliating himself Nan goes for the
direct attack on the robot but drive
Knight successfully uses his tactical
transformation Mark Knight and kicks the
monster into the air as the monster
floats above him he once again uses his
tactical transformation transforming
into flying Chariot to propel himself
above Nan once there he transforms into
his Bishop form and punches nen into the
ground yet as he does this the slippery
C manages to change his size and slips
into the drive night suit before it
slices him apart from the inside using
feline retribution
after the duo separates Drive Knight
uses his tactical transformation Mark
gold while opposite him neon unleashes
flying slashes directed at the cyborg
yet the hero is simply unharmed due to
the strength and gold armor provided by
the transformation which you know I'm
going to cut this off here for one
second actually makes no sense like gold
is one of the heaviest and most
malleable medals on the planet you can
quite easily on a hot day war a gold
ring if you're not careful I just love
the idea that gold equals the strongest
form because you know Rich equals gold
anyways the two of them and then engage
in another brief scuffle nen once again
slips into drive Knight's body while
inside of the S-Class the CRA slips
around the body and attacks the hero
from unpredictable angles leaving Drive
KN susceptible to life-threatening
injuries asnen is about to release his
feline retribution on the hero's body
again Drive Knight uses his big brain
cyborg computer brain and thinks up a
counter raising the internal temperature
to an extreme level forcing the monster
out as he tries to escape Drive Knight
gets a hold of the monster and uses
silver to stab the cardr and the Torso
from behind before he emulates the dying
monster standing there the team leader
sigar couldn't be happy with how the
fight win but questions why Drive Knight
hadn't come earlier and where he' been
for the last 2 days Drive Knight tells
him on how his method of combat is
analyzing the opponents first and in the
past few days he had been infiltrating
the monster Association while Gathering
as much Intel as possible he flips out
the laser screen showing extremely
detailed info on all of the monsters
that he's heard of or come across he
refrained from heading it to the heroes
before they clashed because he knows for
a fact that there is a traitor among
them asking sigar about the current
situation he learns that literally all
capable aass Heroes Have being
incapacitated and the hero Association
headquarters is wide open for an attack
by the strongest monsters hearing that
drive Knight is worried about the
association being attacked Singa argues
that it's impossible for the monsters to
go there since it's literally designed
by middle Knight yet this is exactly
what dve Knight actually fears instead
he exposes to Singa how Botho Knights
are linked to transmitted data inside of
the monster Association and that one of
his Knights had been captured by the
monsters probably you know the one that
child Emperor came across the Intel that
they would have gotten from the robot
could potentially allow the monsters to
control all of Botho Knights inside of
the hero Association which means that
the building could be taken down from
the inside panicking over the
information that he just received and
the possible traitor being booy second
guard grabs his Communicator trying to
contact blast when all of a sudden a
beam of energy completely burns his hand
off terrifying the team director before
them somehow the damaged mechanical bot
G5 had managed to rise back up and due
to the extremely intense last battle
Drive Knights incapable of fighting
against it clanking around in front of
them G5 transforms into a smaller
version of himself that isn't so damaged
in an attempt to completely annihilate
them all yet a sudden ray of light
appears as the king of Broken Back
stories JS drops down from the sky above
and completely destroys the transformed
monster in front of the scared Heroes
moments later Jos takes the support team
in Wagar to an area guarded by the hero
Association
while also defeating several monsters
along the way after arriving the other
support Heroes all start getting treated
for their injuries taking gas starts
tending to his own wound and call S to
tell the letter that Wagar has
successfully been rescued so finally you
know for the second time they managed to
save the young one he then tosses the
phone to Jos who has a short
conversation with s during the call S
thanks the hero for his work apologizes
for leaving him out of the initial
battle as they thought he may have been
a traitor and finally starts to ask for
a favor skipping away from him over the
drive though it's showing in a flashback
that as he took Nan's body away for
experimentation it's revealed that the
cat monster was actually still alive and
mentioned someone to drive night who can
easily defeat the monster association's
Executives with one punch having
overheard this Jos obviously realized
that his Sensei was fighting against the
monster Association in his own way
because of this he tells s that he has
no intention of following any orders
from the hero Association and hangs out
the cell walking over to the child he
just saved Jus trusts wagen m and foshi
Kia before preparing to enter the
Monster association's Hideout seeing him
start to get ready to invade the base
seeking our hands Jos the Intel that
drive not received in his studying of
The Hider over the previous two days
elsewhere and the association's
underground maze poty poty prisoner has
been absolutely pummeled by Goo getting
blasted through multiple walls until he
lays there battered and bruised
completely unable to move however as he
does lay there a big shiny black leg
muscle appears directly beside him
revealing super Eloy dark who had
managed to stumble upon him at the right
time weekly PTY fills him in on the
situation as opposite the two huge men a
dark bulked up figure of G steps out
skipping away from the bodybuilding
S-Class Heroes we find that the three
Disciples of atomic Samurai have also
Fallen to the evil water monster child
Emperor who had come back to this
hellish maze finds them beaten and
bruised and instantly rushes towards the
injured a class however as the be aass
warns him a sudden shot of extremely
high pressure water jets out towards the
child and instantly realizing that this
is the perfect situation to be in as he
can use the same ability again child
Emperor uses his robot's flesh freezing
breath completely holding and
crystallizing every Speck of the evil
water headed towards the young child
sadly we get a worst case scenario here
for the boys though as jellyfish who had
already been stunted on by the child
walks into the room angered with how it
was already easily defeated it asks to
lend water a hand and eliminating this
brainy hero yet the evil water monster
turns around and sucks the oil out of
the jellyfish bring ing the previous
attack child Emperor used on him
completely ineffective due to the oil
being harder to freeze than water being
able to escape the ice prison the water
monster shoots off one of those high
pressure jet sprays that connects
directly with child Emperor's League
skipping away from the young one we find
Jos boasting it directly towards the
monster Association headquarters while
reviewing the Data Drive Knight provided
to singar earlier on looking at the
strongest monsters he notes that all of
the cardr are Troublesome opponents and
there is no time to come up with any
good strategies although he he does
consider the possibility that scammer
has already taken them all out by
himself elsewhere and the monster
Association base fleshy flesh and
scammer run in circles neither having
any sense of direction sa suggests
contacting the other Heroes to see
what's going on but remember how fleshy
fles had lost his communication device
well he just straight up lies saying
that the other S-Class heroes are
competent and will be fine by themselves
yet I know one into fleshy flesh all of
these S-Class Heroes who are meant to be
able to take down demon Level Threats
are completely overwhelmed and nearing
the brink of death in their own fights
sweet masks absolutely petrified at the
absolute ugliness of fer ugly zombie man
might just become dust at the hands of
homeless Emperor Pig Gods literally
struggling not to become gum's next meal
Atomic is completely lump at the hands
of black a and dark shine and poty putty
prisoner are continuously being beaten
to a pulp by G even with all of this not
looking good for the hero Association
there's still one facing a c without a
care in the world obviously the number
two tatsumaki has absolutely obl lated
guro and began to rip out the human
inside of him thinking of head though
the esper had actually planted a fake
human inside of the monster and it's
reveal that it's just another decoy
instead has shown that the real person
behind all of the plans inside of this
monster Association lies deep within the
lowest levels of The Hideout this
beautiful woman of ample proportions
called psychos lays and the comfort of
her base cradling a glass of wine in her
hand while confidently planning how
she'll Bunch up all of the cardr onto
tatsumaki once they're done handling all
of the heroes themselves
her true plan is to go down as a totally
unseen obscenity that revolutionized the
world into a greater place yet for her
she sadly miscalculated a few things by
the true strength of tataki who just
like that has literally managed to fill
out pyos pyos is utterly shocked by this
having prepared several relay points to
cover the large distance and ensure her
location was Kept Secret she surmounts
that tataki was able to detect the tiny
amount of telepathic waves coming out of
guo's puppet and trace it back to the
source above her tataki yells at psychos
to come out and join the party and
restrains her with her psychic powers
psychos tries to call for any of C to
help her and remembers that overgrown
Rover is still free to move she utilizes
her maximum telepathic output and orders
Rover to mobilize and attack tou Mari
sadly for her though Rover is actually
already occupied with bang bomb and Fuki
skipping over there we see that Rover is
absolutely determined to blast the three
of them into shreds probably annoyed
with the last fight that he had leaving
the group all scared and running for
their lives silver and bomb who are worn
out and out of the perfect shape due to
their previous battles just do their
best to hide behind a wall however Rover
is able to hear them and leaps at them
before charging another one of his
lethal hated blasts shooting the blast
at the trio as expected that all three
of them were to be taken out yet once
the impact settles it's showing that
Fuki is bleeding and has actually
managed to curve the attack away with a
new buffed protective shielding though
she explains that she can't exactly
withstand too many direct attacks there
is actually no way to avoid them either
thinking on the spot Fuki instead comes
up with the idea of reinforcing silver
and bomb's bodies telling them to
quickly Escape out of the monster's
range while she takes the last hit
herself instantly Rover shoots off
another one of his Sonic heat waves
however with those two old boys rests
and backs feeling brand new both silver
and bomb managed to take the shot
themselves while defending Fuki pretty
much saving her life quickly following
on this the old school jro then fed
their techniques together to complete
the cross Fang dragon slayer fist move
which connects directly with overgrown
Rover bang and bomb finished the
combination attack on the pup leaving
Fuki amazed at both of them as she
believes Rover has been defeated she is
especially Amazed by bomb who she
previously thought was just a normal old
man and because of this actually tries
recruiting him into a group not
realizing that Rover is already getting
back up tired of playing with this dude
bom and Silva take their stances again
and frustration bang then asks the
doctor set and behave and to the
surprise the monster actually eles
letting them pass quickly however while
this Trio manages to get the doggy in
control tataki who's probably a lot
closer to her sister than she realizes
senses for bokei meanwhile fleshy flesh
and sight armor and now seen riding
around in a mine card trying to get to
the monster King's Le it's revealed that
they are now been led by Monaco a random
weak unranked monster that they've taken
hostage in secret though Monaco is
actually trying to take out the idiot s
classes without them realizing he
secretly plans to jump off the cart at
just moment he switches it to another
rail sending them down towards their
deaths but after seeing how far the
droppers off his side the monster
actually gets way too scared and doesn't
go through with his own plans instead
the three end up in the monster mines
where they are farming for gold and
other ores to sustain their organization
seeing the absolutely blank faces of the
three Muppets inside the mine cart the
miners quickly lash out and attack the
carriage with the poor Mike wasowski
looking monster shrieking and Terror as
he watches both baly and flashy
instantaneously disappear from inside of
the cart with Absol abute ease both of
the two overpowered Heroes obliterate
the hell out of the area they've just
entered then just as quickly as the exit
of the cart both of the heroes then land
back inside of their vehicle yet one of
the monsters outside of the cart pinb
his cape ripping him straight back out
back in the cart as it like actually
hasn't stopped here it's showing that
the tracks literally come to the final
drop sacrificing himself Mike quickly
grabs a hold of fleshy flesh's leg in an
attempt to bring him down and take out
the S-Class honestly love this little
guy as expected flashy fles something
darts out of the car with the little
still stuck to him slashing the other
monsters around the area looking over to
his side though he once again sees Sama
yet this time man literally has a bag of
gold that he's trying to run off with
swiftly the two then jump back into
another cart but as the body grabs onto
the little monster he accidentally loses
the gold bag and the process shattering
his future hopes and dreams meanwhile
and still under touch with Mike's
restraint psychos reaches out for a
special election in order to fight the
esper at its full strength after
grabbing the liquid psychos emits an ear
shattering scream and declares that she
is much stronger than guu guo elsewhere
with the two body Improvement lovers
true hell has broken loose before dark
shine as go has pretty much lost his
mind not thinking and just attacking
over and over again suddenly as super
Eloy calls him a monster G snaps back to
reality as technically he was actually
asleep attacking on pure Instinct from
the moment Putty Putty prisoner had
Disturbed him dark shine launches Adam
and attacks the now awake hero Hunter
but after being pummeled G simply stands
there challenging the reasoning for dark
shine even being a hero in the first
place as well as the entire hero
society's way of thinking popping out
those Immaculate muscles dark shine
unleashes a devastating tackle that
pierces through G's guard with ease and
sends him flying back through multiple
layers of the monster Association G's
ribs are completely shattered by the
blow but he soon recovers and begins
using his techniques to fight against
the hero firstly he uses water stream
Rock smashing fist to pumble the large
man followed by Whirlwind iron cutting
first to land a complete Onslaught that
makes the indestructible hero consider
the possibility of defeat and his entire
reasoning with actually becoming a hero
in the first place Rec convincing
himself that he dark shine Has the
strength to take down this base of a
monster he then uses his full power to
punch go and uses his prolific super
aloy bazooka but to his complete and
utter shock go meets his fist with a
blow of his own and in that exact moment
G also finally proceeds to an even
higher level of strength with his
limiter beginning to Break Meanwhile
Sama who's absolutely stressing over his
damaged Cape is still with fleshy flesh
who just happens to be giving him a on
his own skills then that like weird
manga moata one piece conspiracy combo
eily up on their surface they not spoken
about spiritualist Jos worries that his
sensei's clothing may have been damaged
just I love this series man skipping
back down to the espers below psychos
and tataki continue their battle tataki
grabs psychos with a psychic restraint
and pulls her up in return psychos grabs
tataki and pulls her down causing the
two to Rocket towards each other psychos
smashes through the floor with saam
fleshy flesh and man are currently
cruising and completely collides with
him not caring about the others though
both of the isers Clash in a brilliant
flash with the combined Powers creating
bolts of psychic energy that send
several spectating monsters shooting off
pushing back the two esas throw each
other back the evil woman then declares
that this is the day tataki will lose
and it's her fault for pushing her this
far tataki though changes the subject
and asks her about tario knowing that
there is another child beside Wagar
while effortlessly killing the pathetic
spectating monsters as she speaks
somewhere else in the monster
Association tario actually finds King
and runs to him in relief King though
immediately shouts for tario to stop
mistakenly believing the boy to just be
another shape-shifting monster in
Disguise quickly calling him out for it
and that insanely typical one punch
fashion is actually revealed that an
invisible monster was sneaking up behind
tiio but reveals himself and fleas
thinking that King had seen through his
invisibility with this king holds taro's
hand and they walk off together the
invisible monster runs down a corridor
door but suddenly a slime grabs him and
Smothers the poor monster it's showing
that the Slime is the heart of a roochi
who is now absorbing the monster's blood
in order to revive himself so he somehow
I guess did survive s's you know like
serious punch anyway sensing the massive
battle between the two espers nearby
arochi slowly crawls towards them over
with the girls psychos unleashes a
psychic eye blast which tataki manages
to repel the blast split apart
destroying a few monsters unfortunate
enough to be in its path bringing up the
question again tataki demands psychos
answer her while she unleashes a
telekinetic punch which staggers the
leader of the monster Association
allowing the number two hero to subdue
her having been caught pyos explains
that there was another child brought in
by Royal repper although she doesn't
know where he went and that the only
other Outsiders in the headquarters
under n rank's private Squad and go as
tataki interrogates psychos they are
interrupted by sweet mask who informs
them of the deaths of the mercenary
Squad by his hand after they changed
into enemy monsters after hearing this
tataki berates the hero for his actions
and inability to handle his opponent in
those kind of situations suddenly the
fight is interrupted by a roochi who
then shows up on a block and begins
absorbing many monsters who had gathered
around before releasing a large scale
attack on tataki with his multiple
dragon heads this enables psychos to
break free from Tatam maki's control as
she is like obviously getting attacked
by someone else right now and after
escaping she commands Orochi to join her
so that his tremendous energy can
amplify her psychokinesis and with this
increased power they can surely win in
response the weakened Orochi reaches out
to psychos with his gooey body very
calmly tataki watches as psychos plops
into orochi's ingesting body she thinks
that she'll easily just be able to rip
her back out if needed Orochi then
merges with psychos only to reveal that
he fully plans to take control of her
instead after a mental battle between
the two pyos takes control of the merger
and starts to fight tatsumaki although
arochi reveals that he still has a level
of control at times as shown when
psycho's face deteriorates into a mass
of Flesh resembling his own AR's dragons
down below fire another round of energy
blasts although tataki easily kills them
tataki and the two villains Clash the
bolts of energy destroy more of the
headquarters while fighting the hero
notes how much more difficult
maintaining her barrier has become and
the fusion increases the gravity around
tatsumaki although the hero proclaims
gravity manipulation will have no effect
on her as she feels an increased
pressure within her barrier from the
fused body a larger white form of
psychosis with long flowing ha emerges
capping the hero's barrier in her hands
psychos explains how she switched the
inside of the barrier with the outside
corrupting it tataki realizes that she
can't disable the barrier and pyos
gleefully remarks that the energy she's
pouring into the barrier combined with
tatsumaki's own energy output will keep
increasing the internal pressure but
also knows that if she releases the
barrier she'll be crushed by the
overwhelming gravity psychos declares
Tatam maki's flesh and blood won't go to
waste and the female hero begins to
bleed from her head and many different
parts of her body due to the tremendous
strain being put on her meanwhile the
funky Joo Flash and Baldi are trying to
escape this all ingesting sticky stuff
that's following after them through the
association a string of aachi blubber
jumps out and tries getting Sarma only
to slip off that shiny scalp of hers
somehow this ends up offending our body
who throws a fat punch straight at the
monster cells destroying a bunch of them
and shaking the whole place however as
this actually happens psychos shels and
pain releasing tat Miki from her grasp
she notes that a large portion of cells
was suddenly eliminated having been
obliterated by saam's punch but also
wonders what that slippery feeling was
just before being destroyed King informs
the other Heroes that he just secured
tiio and he's hitting towards the
surface tataki complimenting Kang's
skills declares that with the child's
safety secured she no longer needs to
hold back and prepares to fight pyos and
aochi with their full power deep inside
the association G continues his beat
down on super Eloy dark shine he slips
past a punch from dark shine and
delivers a strike that forces the hero
to drop down down coughing standing
above the S-Class G taunts darkshine who
looks at him in complete fear it's
explained that when he was a child dark
shine was a frail weight clean unable to
participate in sports and other physical
activities his Frailty left him unable
to build any form of self-confidence on
his 15th birthday though his parents
gave him a set of 3 Kg dun Bells then
from that day onwards he lifted every
single day gradually increasing the
weight until the amount he could lift
was immeasurable his progress through
this built up his confidence to the
point he eventually joined the hero
Association and continued his search for
an opponent who could push him to his
limits as G continues his assault though
dark shine realizes that he was never
looking for a real fighter rather he
sought a fight that could give him a
satisfying Victory the instantly thought
of injury flashes through dark shine's
head the most powerful fear had long
forgotten begins to grow and overwhelm
him completely crowding his thoughts
dting forth G kicks him in the stomach
and pin him to the ground while a follow
up kick to the chest
he moves the strike at dark Shan's ears
but pulls back when the hero Yelps in
fear standing above the cowering hero
now gal judges his assault to be akin to
bullying a pathetic evil compared to
what he aims to become in the future
suddenly G's joints start cracking and
the dark marks on his body crawl towards
his face then even more randomly psychic
barriers are created by tatsumaki that
surround dark shine and pull him up as
the ceiling of the room collapses in
leaving G on the ground amidst the
falling Rubble tataki then drags the
entire monsterous Association
headquarters to the surface she
simultaneously creates protective
barriers around the entire Strike Team
except for flashy flash who lost his
locator and zombie man whose clothes
were destroyed by homeless Emperor the
barrier around Pig God is broken by gums
while Ian breaks his own to rescue the
unconscious members of naran's private
Squad the intense energy coming off her
vibrates through the whole area
literally cracking the surface of the
planet as kataki fully tears the
association out of the ground King
onario are able to reach the surface
unharmed and are found by Geno who
incinerates a large portion of orochi's
mass around them the three then spectate
the ongoing battle in dis Skies up there
tataki and psychos both emerg from the
top of the surface monster Association
base ready to continue their battle the
aftermath of Tatam maki's base lift can
be seen from miles around and is
broadcasted on television the severity
of the damage inspires many previously
wounded Heroes to start hitting towards
the scene and this is the
story as midle watches the news from the
hospital he decid to participate in the
fight with the monster Association
despite his injuries but he's not the
only one mman Rider and tank top Master
have both left their beards to assist
the civilians surrounding the battle
having found their beds empty tank top
doctor explains the subliminal messaging
derived from tank top Master's tank top
causing the tank topper Army to chase
after tank top master in attempt to help
oh my God that line guys please sub help
of course the blizzard group who just
can't sit idly and watch as the tank
tops get the spotlight also Rush after
them as well the only people to stay
behind are the injured martial artists
in the hospital who watch as all of the
heroes depart meanwhile fet's group is
stuck under the remaining Rubble left
over from the enormous technique as saam
and the monster which introduces itself
as Monaco to them try getting flashy out
of the crumbling debris the trio starts
having a casual many conversation
together all the while the world around
them is completely falling to BS psychos
taunts tataki but the heroin notices
that the monster Fusion seems to be
gaining power from its roots and targets
the St beneath to see the connection the
attack fails to work and psychos respond
in turn with their own beam attack which
cuts into the ocean and sers a large
part of the Earth's crust launching it
into space the SE area then slams back
down into the water seeing a massive
shock wave and tsunamis back around the
entire planet tataki is shocked by the
power displayed and realizes that it
could not have been attained naturally
having seen the attack Jos notes that
the energy involved is of an
undetectable scale and appears poised to
engage but King employs him to leave the
fight to tatsumaki and help flee the
scene with tario up in the sky psychos
tells tatsumaki about a Godlike
existence that she witnessed when she
was fusing with a roochi she explains
her plan to absorb all life on the
planet and become the Earth itself a
plan that touch a Maring marks growing
angry that she has still not being
acknowledged by the other espers cyos
and arochi launch a Relentless attack on
tataki tataki avoids the attack and
confirms the evacuation of the
surrounding areas before lifting a
series of massive chunks on the sea
which holds the tsunamis in their paths
she then launches them at psychos and
arochi in a barrage the fusion tries to
intercept the rocks with the energy
beams but tataki is able to hit and
engulf them with the remainder of the
Rocks once again pyos and arochi emerge
unharmed though and the fighters engaged
in a massive psychic battle that creates
a gigantic Whirlwind in the skies above
them T uses decoys made of rocks to hide
a position from psychos and infiltrates
the fusion by climbing inside of them
from the base of the pet sto by
disguising herself as energy and
reducing in her output she's able to
discern the position of psycho's True
Body and uses a rendering attack that
crushes the fusion of psychos and aochi
from inside of their own barrier however
the fusion still regenerates from the
attack and Spears tatsumaki through her
left hand before tatsumaki can coun her
she's impaled through the other hand the
Fusion Monster then discharges
electrical shocks to stun tataki and
make her lose control of her powers
causing Atomic Samurai and poty putty
prisoner who just arrived on the scene
to fall to the ground losing their
barriers created by tataki
with the esper now rendered helpless the
disfigured Fusion of psychos and Orochi
prepared to finish her off with a
massive energy attack just as they
launch their beams it is intercepted by
a wave of energy from the ground which
launches both beams into the sky it is
revealed that our mle man and shining
armor the King was actually able to
divert the insane blast and save tataki
from certain Doom standing there
together Jos and the now free tataki
prepared to face off against a now
regenerated psychos and arochi meanwhile
saitama and Mano are still busy in the
efforts to free flashy flash which is
like honestly hilarious when you think
about it the dude could probably just
dart out of this pile at any point to
make time go quicker manaco shows Sait a
quick trick to alleviate his hunger
watching this from his rubel grave
fleshy flesh is silently grateful that
nobody will witness him in such a
humiliating position back on the surface
the battle between the two Heroes and
the regenerated fusion monsters
continues while Goos is busy holding off
the energy beams from orochi's dragons
pyos shoots a massive energ blast
towards tatsumaki seeing this Jos
manages to appear in front of tatsumaki
and helps her by shooting an energy
blast towards the fusion monsters energy
beam as both of the respective energy
attacks Clash Gils tataki to hurry up
and pull all the heroes out of the
monster Association headquarters while
he pushes through the energy beam from
pyos as Jos has a brief clash with a
Fusion Monster he manages to negate one
of their energy attacks but is a
mobilized and seemingly in no longer
fighting condition however tataki was
successfully able to pull all of the
hero in the tower psychos then shoots
another energy beam in an attempt to
finish them off but tatsumaki now
somewhat free stops the energy beam
while holding her fellow hero she then
deflects the attack away and starts
asking psychos a question regarding her
sister Fuki which absolutely terrifies
the merged monster Fuki who is now on
the ground along with bang and bomb
takes a look at the sky noticing that
his sister is Concentra a mess of
psychic power realizing what she's doing
she states that tataki plans to end the
fight with her next move floating
opposite her psychos is impressed by T
of mari's increasing power shortly
before suddenly being Twisted by her
along with the entirety of the monster
association's headquarters as blood from
the Twisted Fusion of psychos and arochi
drips into the underground we see that
Atomic Samurai is back up and now
looking for his disciples child Emperor
is trying to communicate with zombie man
but there is no signal of where he is
only the locat beacon meanwhile sa asks
Monaco if whatever is happening is the
work of her boss and after having this
confirmed wonders if his house is going
to be destroyed by the resulting
destruction the je then resumes digging
trying to free fleshy flesh from being
trapped under these rocks elsewhere King
is climbing some stairs with tario but
the buildings around them suddenly
collapse and they are forced to go back
down the stairs instead above them all
tataki is still locked in battle
twisting up psychos and possibly
bringing the massive fight to an actual
end suddenly though the small isper STS
coughing blood causing her to wonder if
she's actually used too much of her own
power noticing that tataki is starting
to get weaker psychos uses a move that
works as a smoke screen in an attempt to
escape from the bed then while heading
away quickly transforms into a jet
before trying to consume all of the
blood from the humans and the city to
replenish yourself tataki senses that
their presence has been divided into
seven due to psychos using the same
technique that tataki used on her before
in response she manages to create a
giant psychic barrier surrounding them
so that the monster won't be able to
escape annoyed psychos tries to pierce T
mak's heart using a laser attack as she
believes that the hero needs to take all
of your con conentration to maintain the
enormous barrier this is then
technically a true chance to finish her
off but as she blasts her attack
forwards all she ends up hitting was a
dummy created by the hero tataki now
having figured out the location of the
monster within the smoke prepares
herself however Drive night then also
appears and joins the battle to help the
struggling isur letting tataki do a
thing by just controlling the barrier
Drive Knight and the Fusion Monster
continue to clash down below Jos appears
before the other S-Class Heroes and
informs them of the current situation
explains that tataki is near her limit
so anyone who was able to assist in the
battle needs to before joining the
battle in the sky himself Pig God who is
now also on the ground alongside the
other S-Class Heroes begin spting
everyone out of his stomach that he had
managed to save aan regains his
Consciousness and is informed by Peg God
about what happened he then expresses
gratitude towards the fat hero for
saving him and the ninki squad suddenly
the master appears before him and after
a short reunion tries to think of a way
to have the Fusion Monster In The Sky
meanwhile tank top Master who's like
arrived near the battlefield begins
rescuing the civilians from being
trapped by the falling de breeze he
amazes the other Heroes standing nearby
by easily lifting a large piece of
rubble whereas all of the other Heroes
had been completely unable to move it
before afterwards a medical helicopter
appears in the sky and attempts to
rescue the injured people but it's sadly
stopped by tatsumaki's invisible barrier
after asking lightning Max where tataki
is tank top Master tells M ryer that he
will head over to the monster
Association headquarters to support the
es hero and recommends that M rer stay
and continue with the rescue operations
tank top Master then in honestly just
one of the sickest modes of Transport
proceeds to lift a transmission tower
before throwing it into the air while
grabbing a hanging wire to travel
straight towards the monster Association
headquarters through the air himself and
a flashback 5 minutes before the robot
enter the battlefield Drive Knight a SE
observing the battle between tatsumaki
and the psychos Orochi Fusion unfold
from afar he expresses his interest in
collecting a sample of the fusion but du
to his prior battle between him and Nan
his remaining energy reserves are
extremely limited around him the ground
all over Z city has been ripped up due
to the highly powerful psychic move
performed by tatsumaki and due to this
drive Knight quickly notices a large
damaged underground energy cable beneath
him in order to join the battle against
the fusion Drive Knight proceeds to head
down and actually take some of the
energy from the cable by sticking his
hand into it this caused a major power
outage in the near by city but allowed
jve Knight to actually arrive back at
the scene back in the present now where
the heroes are composing the themselves
and devising a plan sweet mask is seen
recounting his battle with fur ugly he
berates himself for curling up like a
baby and cowering in front of his
ugliness during the fight the other
Heroes finally notic sweet mask and cast
him multiple different glances du to his
like immense Pride as a self-proclaimed
true hero sweet mask mistakes them all
for looks of disapproval as he thought
the heroes overheard the request for
help he gave to tat a Mari during his
fight with fur ugly he further mistakes
child Emperor's friendly gesture for him
to stay in the rear guard as a personal
insult to his own strength instead a
might decides that if the news of his
defeat was to be published his
reputation as an idol hero would be
tarnished therefore he considers killing
everyone on the scene and covering it up
by explaining it as the work of some
crazy monster as sweet master PRS to
show his true self to the heroes around
Ian interrupts by asking whether he's
fine luckily this causes sweet M to have
a flashback about an encounter with
blast there blast is seen at some point
in the past having saved sweet mask from
some monster and this memory causes a
site to snap out of his murderous intent
and smash his own head on some Rubble he
then tells Ian that his outfit wasn't
matching as an excuse for his aggressive
behavior while making a final remark
about needing to retain self-control
elsewh on the battlefield and having
seen super Eloy dark shine sitting on
the ground with a sad expression on his
face the other Heroes come closer to him
Putty Putty prisoner and zombie men are
shocked after the S-Class hero explains
how he lost against go dark shine then
retells his experience about go to the
other Heroes admitting his complete
defeat against the hero Hunter and also
noting that the letter will show up
again with no one being able to stop him
now meanwhile go who is deep underground
as he has been buried in the many
falling debris begins rising up slowly
Rising he Ponders the idea on why the
more he is beating the more he feels
like he is getting stronger coming to
the conclusion that through these pretty
much like zinai boasts of strength he is
one step closer to becoming the monster
that he wishes to become and interally
thinking he fully envisions himself as
despar incarnate Desiring to make the
world become the way he wants it to be
and with that his body once more begins
transforming into a more monsterous
State back on the surface and after
learning what happened to Super Eloy
dark shine sweet mask is angered seeing
how truly pathetic his fellow hero is
proceeding to kick him hard multiple
times in an attempt to make him realize
that every time a hero Falls they have
to get back up eventually super aloy
follows his fellow Heroes and decides to
stand up to fight again much to the
relief of others toic Samurai suggest to
cooperate together to defeat the boss of
the monster Association much to everyone
surprised as usually the dude only works
with his disciples soon after this tank
top Master also arrives on the scene
having entered the battle in his own way
and with his arrival they continue
discussing their plan soon also shown up
on the scene as well bang bom and Fuki
all of whom were like previously
excluded from the operation join the
S-Class Heroes on the surface most of
the heroes that like were on the surface
were completely unaware of them even
being excluded in the first place and
because of this a Atomic Samurai
proceeds to question child Emperor on
why people were excluded from the
mission after everything is explained to
them going over how they weren't sure
who the traitor was bang forgives child
Emperor Fuki though who realizes how
badly injured her sister is plads with
the heroes around her to assist her
sister as she was beginning to lose
Consciousness up in the sky during the
battle as Drive KN and genos protected
unconscious tatsumaki from pyos she has
a flashback to 18 years ago and some
research institute where she was being
held during this flashback a a rampant
monster manages to escape going rogue
inside of the Institute leaving the
young isper alone in her cell unable to
escape yet and those moments of true
despare the one and only blast shows up
and saves tatsumaki quickly recognizing
her insane amount of power and going on
to convince the young girl to use her
powers to protect her own family back in
reality tatsumaki suddenly regains
Consciousness and without delay
continues her battle over with the robot
Drive Knight chases psychos into a
tunnel while exchanging a ser Ser of
attacks with a combination monster
getting back into the action herself now
tataki creates multiple obstacles within
the tunnel to trap psychos allbe it
unsuccessfully as psychos manages to
exit the tunnel she is caught by
surprise when Jos runs by and jumps onto
her to H her with his Jets thus allowing
dve Knight to follow up and do the same
leaving the two Heroes alone on the
monolith of a monster preparing to
finish it off instantly the two beas and
embedded Bots both unleash a blast of
powerful beams directly into pyo's jet
overloading her with energy however
psychos manages to break down the energy
and release it back at the two heroes
from out of the wound that they just
created blasting them back and leaving
them plunging towards the ground freed
from the two eClass Heroes psychos then
proceeds to make a final attempt to
eliminate tatsumaki by firing another
energy Beam at her yet coming an
absolutely clutch tank top master was
able to intercept the blast with a huge
Boulder that he threw from the ground
below down with the ground team fi's
assistance and increasing tank top
Master's physical capabilities helps the
hulking giant throw a series of large
Boulders at psychos buying the other
Heroes valuable time to recuperate Drive
Knight manages to get over to Jos and
request assistance by fusing together
and maximizing the power output JS ends
up agreeing to this dodgy idea but wants
his fellow bot that his core is near its
limit not worried about the possibility
of a possible detonation the two then
form together until the Tactical
combination Mark promoted Rock which
also just happens to distract psycho's
attention for a moment seeing this
tankto master proceeds to throw an
entire building at the monster of course
though this time the rocketing object
contains Atomic Samurai Putty Putty
prisoner and super alloy dark shine who
all upon connecting with the giant
monster used a series of combination
attacks Atomic Samurai hits her with
atomic beline slash Putty Putty prisoner
with his vibration Dark Angel rush and
dark shine with a super alloy missile to
power the fusion down towards the ground
below at this moment psychos separates
from a roachie but to her dismay bang
and bomb appear using their combination
attack the prolific cross Fang dragon
slayer fist to incapacitate the falling
monster still above tataki then prepares
the finish of aochi causing the ground
to start shaking meanwhile and down
below still flashy fles states that his
arm is stuck under something heavy T
sarm discovers a cube like object
resembling the one blast hell during the
previous flashback with tataki before
fleshy flesh could pull his arm out from
underneath this thing the ground in
front of them is suddenly pulled out by
tatsumaki effectively breaking fleshy
flesh's Katana instakill and the pro
which was also stuck in the trouble
above them tataki charges up the Spire
she just crafted with psychic energy as
she redirects it towards roochi ready to
deliver the final blow seeing the mass
quickly approaching Mano like remember
the little monster while he attempts to
escape using the whole created with
fleshy flesh's arm was stuck in but the
three quickly noticed something
mysterious dwelling there weirdly they
see a large humanoid creature crouched
in a fetal position resembling something
they call God now above them a
scattering of stars spread around the
figure implying that the three are now
observing Pary fabric of reality and
towards somewhere deep within the
universe now I'm going to cut myself off
for like one second here everyone just
to say subscribe and leave a like on
this video and help push me towards like
200k cuz oh my God this is just an
insane like a absolutely huge video that
I've put so much time into like marata
and one are absolute pure goats and I
can't wait to see what season 3 with
mappa is going to look like I really
really hope that they somehow like get
some freelance artists like the ones
from season 1 that would be so amazing
to have have like a bunch of these
season 1 freelance artists come back and
do some stuff like season 3 in the main
fights and everything oh my God I'm just
like creaming over the idea of it right
now anyway anyway back with the series
Trio of slightly incapable Heroes sa a
flashy flesh and the monster manaco well
as they appear into that mysterious hole
are unable to see anything multiple
lightings generated by the monster also
don't function as apparently entities
with in this hole do not interact with
most electromagnetic waves suddenly a
voice appears in the head of the three
probably God and offers to bestow Powers
upon the three of them coming in out of
absolutely nowhere though blast and
veins by appearing through a wormhole
and explaining to the three that due to
their physical contact with a mysterious
Cube they are able to talk to him which
is probably a god of some sort like I
just said before and that Blast has been
collecting these cubes as a hobby The
Voice then reveals blast's true identity
to the three which causes fleshy flesh
to test the purported hero's strength
attacking him but blast easily Dodges
flesh's fleshy cicks thus am meaning his
identity is the the top ranked hero as
they talk blasing decides to take the
three to the surface by generating
another Wormhole meanwhile child Emperor
zombie man and sweet Mar stain in the
rear guard during the battle against
psychos and arochi child Emperor berates
himself for not being an effective
leader and offers zombie man to take up
the role sweet mask on the other hand
refers to zombie man as a suedo monster
and refuses to put trust in him which is
actually like so big coming from what I
assume to be a fox and sheep's clothing
obviously but anyways just a zombie man
is reassuring child emperor of his
capabilities homeless Emperor reappears
from the ground and attacks the rear
guard Heroes during the unexpected
assault amay manages to dodge the energy
spheres but zombie man's body is once
again torn apart as he blocks the shots
for child Emperor back above them tataki
launches the energy sphere at a roochi
and shreds the monster to complete
pieces the spirit itself though
continues drilling into the ground until
it finally stops near a mysterious altar
elsewhere both King and tario are seen
running for encountering a physical
anomaly with these space in front of
them appearing somewhat distorted middle
B who's also running sees the anomaly in
front of them which also prevents him
from recognizing King andario who are
opposite him suddenly pineapple moin and
fet leoshi come out of the supposed
anomaly between them confused as later
revealed by the food battler that this
anomaly acts as a quantum stealth Shield
that covers a tank Wagar comes out of
the tank and hugs tario upon seeing him
butario also expressing relief as Wagar
is safe too Wagar then asks tario about
a child Emperor saved him but he
declines and says that it was King and
the uncle of course referring to G who
saved him as well hearing that child
Emperor might be in more danger Wagar
urgently asks King and middleback to
save him standing there middleb
internally questions if Wagar has really
changed its attitude and the letter
who's still talking says that his dead
will pay for the medical bells of
anyone's heard much to Middle BET's
relief sing guard then shows up hopping
out of the tank and tells both of them
not to be insecure over the power Gap
instead ordering the lower ranked Heroes
to to guard the two kids singar also
tells midle bat and King to stand by in
an area within keep track of the battle
midle bat who was surprised at the hero
Association has someone like sigar
actually obeys him after listening to
what sigar has to say King expresses
disappointment that he couldn't be of
much help when he attracted the Elder
centipede who mistakenly took him for a
strong opponent but assures himself that
scammer will surely show up soon tario
asks King to save the uncle but King
questions who this person is that tiio
keeps referring to wondering if he is
also a hero T replies that he doesn't
know who the uncle really is but just
tells King not to bully him if the hero
does find him middle bet the inions have
a slingshot and the two S-Class Heroes
get onto it with both tario and Wagar
telling them good luck before singar
lasers the Rope instantly flinging the
duo into the air before crashing down
elsewhere outside a bedding cage back
over at HQ suko who's uh suu's sister
remember like that dude who got
absolutely pummeled in season 2 by the
by the guy who took the monster cells
well she is is actually visiting her
brother at the hero Association hospital
and upon being teased by his little
sister suu wakes up and they begin
having a conversation as they talk suku
is surprised that her brother is really
serious about becoming a hero and
helping others once he heals in the
battle tat tamaki's massive psychic
barrier that she used to envelop the
city Z starts Vanishing allowing the
medical helicopter to come and assist
the people that are inside of it tank to
master and Fuki take a look at tataki in
the sky and seeing that his sister is
still alive Fuki is relieved despite
witnessing tatsumaki's enormous psychic
powers again tank to master still
expresses his desire to overcome her
someday just like bro you just got to
chill on that one there look at any
other S-Class hero weaker to overcome
ain't no way you're ever reaching
country level strength with what against
go in season 2 having looked at
tatsumaki in the sky bang surprised that
these selfish solitary S-Class members
would start cooperating with everyone
else he talks to bomb regarding go with
bomb staing that go might have been
inside of the monster Association
headquarters and that the hero Hunter
could have died during tatar's attack
bang however replies that g is not the
one to die so easily and tells his older
brother to not let his guard down just
yet Elsewhere on the battlefield
homeless Emperor St at a severely
injured zombie man while noting that guo
and arochi might have been defeated
sweet Mas then suddenly emerges from the
smoke that was just created by the
energy spheres from homeless empor
attack and attempts to Hur him however
before he can reach homeless Emperor
black is randomly bursts out of the
ground and restrains the a Class Hero
following this fer ugly erupts out of
the ground as well just like black is
did and scares off the top ranked a
Class Hero with his ugly face man I love
the dynamic between fur ugly and um amay
it's it's just too good anyway duud to
his weaknesses against ugly people sweet
M screams out and fear upon seeing F
ugly the fat monster then follows up and
brutally punches sweet mask in the face
severely deforming the hero's face
before he proceeds to Simply tear him
apart and toss him away which is
honestly insane like I never actually
expected sweet master to be just tossed
away like garbage but anyway continuing
after defeating sweet mask F ugly steps
on zombie men's regenerating body and
taunts child Emperor while reading
another punch but is randomly
interrupted by a massive energy orb
launched by homeless Emperor the orb
impacts the ground causing a massive
explosion with atomic Samurai Ian Peg
God and tank to master as well as F ugly
only just avoiding hers Atomic Samurai
tries to contact child Emperor who
seemed to have been caught in the midst
of the explosion but sadly gets no
response just as evil natural water also
emerges from the ground nearby Ian
immediately recognizes this threat and
reades his sword and fear while nearby
Peg God and tank toot Master are barely
able to avoid being eaten by gums who
bursts forth from the rubble all of a
sudden as well Jos crashes down from the
sky in front of Fai Putty Putty prisoner
banging bomb the cyborg then reveals
that due to the extended battle and
drive Knight's negligence of his limit
he is now on the verge of exploding it's
also revealed by Jos that drive Knight
has already left the scene leaving
everyone else to deal with the dire
situation meanwhile putty puty prisoner
decides to go alone to save child
Emperor who is reportedly Buried Alive
by the rebble caused by homeless Emperor
attack while the rest of the heroes
simply try to help Jos Jos however
advises them all to retreat as he plans
to self-destruct and cause as much
damage to the remaining enemies as
possible not wanting this to be the case
though Fuki after some hesitation
refuses to retreat or leave anyone
behind instead she gathers her resolve
and uses her psychic powers to stabilize
genus's core orbe it with extreme
difficulty having witnessed a slow
change in Fuki attitude bang and bom are
amazed at the heroic acts of
selflessness commenting on how the
unconscious hero may become a great
leader in the future turning their
attention the group then observes as
tataki is being chased down by a massive
amount of energy spheres sented her by
homeless Emperor which managed to catch
and seemingly defeat her however it's
actually revealed that she had managed
to swap herself the decoy during the
pursuit and Escape just in time the real
tataki though whining from her injuries
appears before the remaining Heroes of
the ground team and once seeing her
sister becomes furious at seeing her
injuries however Fuki is able to quickly
get the crazed isper to chill out seeing
that tataki is heavily injured and
weakened herself Fuki tries to stop her
from returning to battle but despite her
efforts to convince her tataki states
that Fuki has indeed grown yet decides
to still leave and fight the remaining
monsters as Fuki is lift in tears after
failing to stop his sister Jos reassures
her by telling her that he will assist
tataki in this final showdown realizing
that Jos is about to leave and believing
him to be Reckless bang 2 decides to
accompany the Cyborg and Aid the isper
telling bomb to take her of habuki and
inform him if he spots go suddenly and
out of nowhere the Council of Sword
Masters and spring Mustachio the a Class
Hero then arrive on the battlefield and
notify everyone that they are here to
help assist the heroes against the
remaining monsters Al swe in the battle
tank top Master is seen in his fight
against gums as he struggles to not let
it Chomp down on him until Peg God
luckily manages to show up and save him
tackling the monster so that it spits
him out he then Witnesses F ugly take a
member of the nanki private Squad
hostage before tearing his arm off
seeing him distracted gums takes the
opportunity to try and eat tank top
Master again this time trumping down a
little more successfully than before
tataki temporarily distracts fur ugly by
stopping the monster from ending the
nanki squad member's Life tank top
Master is then also once again rescued
by Peg God who tackles the gladon
monster for a second time having been
saved tank top Master then watches as
Peg God puts the ninki squad and bushy
drill into his mouth to prevent any more
hostages being taken by the enemy
monsters then goes to throw him at the
enemies before launching Peg God tank
top Master tells him to pass on a
message to M Rider that the heroes will
win this fight nearby fur ugly slowly
manages to break free from tatsumaki's
restraint and knocks her back seeing
this tto master rushes forward and uses
his tank top tackle only to be met by a
powerful punch from the monster that
shatters both of his forearms feeling
powerless against the monsters in front
of him he tries to reassure himself that
his tank top is utterly Invincible
shortly before being mercilessly
brutalized and left in a bloody mess and
then ultimately being taken by gums fur
ugly then sets his eyes on and
approaches tataki who was lying on a
nearby Rock heavily injured and weakened
elsewhere and near the edge of the
battlefield a group of Heroes are seen
evacuating the injured civilians in Z
City when all of a sudden Pig God is
shown to approach them from the air
after being launched by Tank Master he
then begins spining out the numerous
members of the nanki private Squad along
with bushy drill and OK matachi from his
mouth and informs the rescue team that
one of them is badly injured and needs
to be treated mman rer approaches Pig
God and asks him about the situation of
the battle to which the big guy tells
him that tank top master has shown up
and it's thanks to the latter that the
heroes have a chance to overcome the
situation obviously not realizing what
just happened to him pigo then further
informs M Ryder and some members of the
tank top Army that tank top Master is
still fighting their their remaining
High ranked monster and passes a message
from their Master to them after
receiving the message from him they are
all unanimously encouraged and continue
the rescue operation more
enthusiastically back on the battlefield
as fur ugly is about to get his hands on
tatsumaki bang arrives at the scene and
pierces through gums with a kick
managing to save tank top master from
the acid in its stomach with genos
instantly following up by incinerating
the inside of the being noticing that
gums was being attacked F ugly quickly
switches his Focus onto bang and tries
to attack him with his face carving
punch however bang skillfully uses his
leg to deflect F ugly's punch straight
back at him knocking the ugly monster
back before then going over to check
tank top Master's condition and state
that the hero's heart has stopped
beating while genos is about to defate
the hero bang grabs his tank top and
snaps it back onto his body this
magically acts as some sort of like
defibrillator as well restarting his
heart and Reviving him through what tank
top Master calls the tank top magic
after bang andos then have a quick check
over tank top Master you're ugly gets
back on his feet and gums who managed to
heal himself sneaks around and grabs the
cyborg by surprise and trapping him
within his Jaws despite bang warning F
ugly that his water stream Rock smashing
fist is the ultimate defense against any
attack and doesn't recommend that the
monster try to attack him F ugly still
attempts to attack bang with an even
more powerful punch than before as F
ugly throws his dignity caving punch at
bang the martial arst once again manages
to redirect his punch towards gums and
then retaliates against F ugly by
unleashing a flurry strikes to push the
ugly monster back after being injured
and forcibly made to spit out JS due to
the punch being redirected into him gums
actually attacks fur ugly as he believed
that it was all on purpose that he was
punched by his fellow monster watching
the breakdown of communication happen
bang and Jos take the opportunity to
leave the two monsters and bring TTP
master and tatsumaki to Fuki in order to
let her heal the injuries back with the
rampaging monsters F ugly then manages
to tear gums in half from the inside
with his own body then being dissolved
by its stomach acid completely turning
him into a new toxic amalgamation of
ugliness over in the water battle Atomic
Samurai and Ian managed to defend
themselves against the multiple
highspeed Jets from the evil natural
water monster I love how I'm just
calling this guy Ian instead of like e
or however you s his actual name cuz I
cannot say his actual name and I'm not
going to even try Ian notes that his
water jets are getting stronger and
actually suspects that it absorbed the
underground water before going on to
wonder what would happen if the monster
makes it and absorbs the entire ocean
even natural water monster then proceeds
to bombard Ian with a multitude of
blasts destroying his sword and
practically sub menting the hero's death
however super Eloy dark shine arrives
and manages to save Ian by quickly
defending him from the monster's deadly
water jets with his own extraordinary
durable body annoyed the massive water
continues to attack super Eloy dark
shine with his water jet only to leave
the hero completely unscathed dark shine
then nonch lightly destroys the entirety
of the monster with a single punch
before stating that it was a nice preure
shower for him elsewhere bang and jenos
are on their way to bring tataki and
tank top Master to Fuki when all of a
sudden the absolutely dreaded black is
suddenly appears in front of them
instantly attacking the heroes after
replicating itself into a multitude of
clones luckily though as bang and Jos
try to defend themselves from all of the
Clones while also protecting the two
wounded Heroes Atomic Samurai and super
Eloy dark shine arrive at the scene and
assist them against the new threat over
in the Clone Battlefield the heroes are
just managing to f off the countless
copies of black is seeing that his
enemies have managed to defend
themselves and that they are proving
difficult against him alone a clone of
black s asks homeless Emperor who was
like nonchalantly sitting on a pile of
rubble and watching the fight from a
distance for assistance however he
refuses to call for help and states that
it's a race to hunt the s-classes
telling the black monster to prove
itself leaving the Clone alone upset as
he leaves it's revealed though that
Homeless Emperor is actually planning to
get rid of black s and the other
monsters after it splits to its maximum
amount and destroys all of civilization
because of this all all the Homeless Man
simply has to do is watch the
battlefield as black is is struggling
against his enemies Jos who's been
transporting the injured back and forth
finally manages to bring tank top Master
to Fuki asking her to heal him shortly
before going back to the battlefield by
himself bom and Fuki are shocked at
seeing tank top Master's injuries with
Fuki expressing doubt if her remaining
power will be enough to save him and
bomb seeing this also asks if his
strength can be drawn upon to help which
Ruki suggests that they might as well
try she then puts her hand and bombs
together on tank top master and using a
telekinesis in combination with the
power being lent by palom manages to
actually begin healing the S-Class hero
as he has seen recovering from his
injuries albe it extremely slowly
suddenly gal erupts from the ground
nearby now with a completely monstrous
appearance and confronts both Fuki and
balb the outer martial artist then
loudly calls for his brother and forming
bang and the other Heroes of G's new
prisons hearing this bang wants to leave
and assist his brother but he's
currently holding off the black his
clone having heard all the info as well
and knowing that he probably wants to
leave Atomic Samurai tells him to go and
assist his brother much to the Elder's
gratitude over on the other side of the
battlefield bom prepars to fight the
almost completely monsterized go while
telling Fuki to stay back with insane
rage G starts engaging in combat with
bomb and the two of them are capable of
holding their own relatively well
against each other Fuki watches the
battle and tries to assist the old man
against the hero Hunter however they are
fighting so fast that their eyes can
simply not follow their attacks as for
iuki appears to lose her Focus G tries
to attack her but bomb manages to block
a strike then purposefully lands a blow
on go that tends on flying away in an
attempt to keep Fuki away from the fight
before immediately rushing towards him
Pig God then appears before Fuki and is
sadly made aware of tank top master who
is lying nearby with severe injuries as
Pig God is worrying about his big friend
Fuki asks for his help in healing tank
top master in a similar way to how she
had just done with bomb beforehand
meanwhile in another front the other
Heroes along with the members of the
Council of Sword Masters are continuing
to Fe off the countless copies of black
ear suddenly tataki is caught by a
massive clone who had just erupted from
the ground before the Clone can squeeze
down on her the goat of all goats Jos
arrives and manages to free touch aaki
from The Hold by incinerating the
monster quickly another large clone
emerges behind Jos and slams his cyborg
into the ground yet Jos immediately
makes use of his suit's burial Escape
functionality to get back to his feet
safely stating that it uses the daa from
when he fought Tatum Mari together the
two of them stand there alone prepare to
face off against the Endless Sea of
black e clones elsewhere F ugly who's
like just that much uglier now arrives
at the battlefield and immediately
demands to fight silver Fang whom he
blames for his current horrifying State
seen his horrific change the Clones
tease him for his ugly State causing few
ugly to angrily respond by shooting an
acid spit on several clones completely
melting them not phased by the dude's
change even though like he totally
should be right now boys big dark giant
attack for your ugly with a super Eloy
double bazooka which the monster
counters with his own forearm melting
punch sadly due to F ugly's increased
strength and new found abilities dark
shine's attack is not only negated but
the acid all over the monster's body
starts to dissolve the hero's hands
following up F ugly then proceeds to
shoot an acid attack at dark shine which
connects directly with his chest causing
him to roll on the ground and reel and
pain seeing what happen to dark shine
zanai advises the others to not face fur
ugly empty-handed and charges Adam with
a sword but as he attacks the monster
manages to catch a sword and instantly
melts it due to the acid covering the
monster's hand having caught The
Swordsman Fe ugly retaliates by spitting
acid onto his face sadly killing him as
the others watch this they are left
utterly terrified by F ugly's new powers
not pH though Atomic Samurai and the
Chan attack him using their respective
techniques almost simultaneously Atomic
Samurai obviously uses his Atomic slash
and the Chan uses his ehi rahu assur
slash only to sadly see their swords
also get melted by the a said with fur
ugly remaining completely unharmed in
the other fight G and bomb continue
battling the outer martial artist
contemplates G's extremely rapid growth
noting that the hero Hunter's newly
customized style has fused every
technique he's ever learned together
thinking on what to do he questions
whether it came about due to
modification or something beforehand bom
resolves not to go down until his
brother arrives and he prepares a
powerful cutting move having concealed
the preparation for his attack bomb
strikes the ground managing to
disorientate go seeing this he then
seizes the opportunity to launch an
attack but is shocked to find that
perfectly matches and cels out the blow
then intiation G throws a single hit
which knocks bomb to the ground sadly
bang arrives just in time to see his
elder brother being defeated noticing
his arrival bom calls out to his bro
warning him about G's extreme growth but
bang remains strong with a stern look in
the direction of his traitorous former
disciple standing there bang comments on
G's miserable State before deciding to
go all out against his former disciple
and pretty much grandson in a Flash they
began engaging in combat where the two
of them extremely capable of fighting
against each other yet even still with
the pure intensity of the fight G
manages to make his former Master bleed
after a brief Clash causing bang to
remark that he is now much more worthy
of teaching than before over in the
other fights and after failing to harm
few are ugly with their respective
attacks the monster throws his full body
melting punch towards Atomic Samurai and
nedan and an attempt to eliminates them
as spring mustachio and Ian rush to
their Master's defenses Amah sacrifices
himself for all of the others by rushing
towards and kicking both Atomic Samurai
and Ian out of the way of the attack
when niran himself shoves his own
student out of the way Amah is instantly
vaporized by the acidic punch from fur
ugly and Nan is mortally wounded being
dissolved from the waist down laying
there on the verge of death Nan
activates his mythical Pearl to pull out
the legendary Sun blade and give it to
Atomic Samurai and trusting him to
rebuild it in the future and find the
moon blade Nan then turns to Spring
Mustachio and tells him to follow his
own path before passing out much to the
sadness of his student meanwhile black
is tells F ugly to not consume his
clones and threatens to kill him if he
dares to not take him seriously however
the fat monster replies that he actually
has a plan for the small man in the
future he will keep all of the blackish
clones around as livestock and therefore
will continue to consume them if needed
he provokes black is to oppose him if
the letter has problems with his ideal
future his behavior angers blackest who
noticing that the heroes have been
wakened from the constant fighting
starts merging his cells into a new and
improved version of himself the golden
is an extremely powerful being resulting
from merging a large amount of his cells
together straight after birthing into
this new form golden s quickly
overwhelms fur ugly stating with
confidence that the lest digestive
fluids are useless against him due to
him having the anti-corrosive properties
of gold now which like they actually got
right this time unlike what the gold
armor with Drive Knight that would
actually melt and just be warped after
one attack the main reason for the value
of gold is its unparalleled corrosive
resistance middles such as gold and
platinum do not corrode visibly because
they are unaffected by oxygen and most
other acids but anyway as the glob
monster himself is slowly getting up
after being brutalized by Golden a he is
suddenly attacked by homeless Emperor
sending multiple energy balls at him
golden is the surprise that he finally
decided to give him a hand with homeless
Emperor stating that it was because it
was unbearable for him to watch any
longer F ugly quickly recovers and gets
up trying to retaliate by spitting acid
towards homeless Emperor however he
manages to block the acidic attack with
his energy spheres and proceeds to
bombard the fat monster with consecutive
balls of energy as the massacre comes to
an end F ugly lies defeated on the
ground shortly before recovering once
again realizing that he is utterly
outmatched by the other Heroes F ugly
slowly leaves homeless Emperor and
golden s or declaring his revenge on
them one day golden is though intends to
finish him off but homeless Emperor
manages to persuade him and to let him F
ugly go stating that the L is still
currently useful for them the golden
inot then switches his Focus onto super
Eloy dark shine who's still trembling in
fear due to suffering damage from fer
ugly digestive fluids standing over the
hero he comments about dark shine's
unworthiness for being an S-Class hero
shortly before then in a punch directly
onto him which sends the hero flying a
considerable distance back towards the
swordsman after leaving his monster
Partners F ugly expresses a desire to
retaliate against them and also bang who
he just you know happens to hate as well
with four clones of Blackish having
watched ugli rant from a distance they
plan between themselves on how to take
him down until middle bat suddenly
appears behind the Clones asking them
whether or not they know the hero
Hunter's location not heing to tell him
though the Clones quickly attack middle
bear in an attempt to kill him stating
that it doesn't matter to a dead man the
hero quickly retaliates against the
Clones annihilating all four of them
with a single swing somewhere behind him
King then emerges from a pile of rubble
and wonders why he is always left alone
back with the three Swordsmen homeless
Emperor begin to attack using his
extreme carpet bombing sending a massive
amount of energy spheres towards them
from the sky Ian and spring Mustachio
managed to defend themselves an atomic
Samurai against the attack by deflecting
the energy balls using their sword
skipping away to somewhere else in this
hellish landscape Jos and touch a Mary
are seen struggling against a large
number of black his clones that are
surrounding them then skipping off
elsewhere after being saved by his
underdone Man Robot and barely surviving
an attack by homeless Emperor by diving
into an opening in the rubble child
Emperor sends booy a message VI his
phone he informs him of the current
situation and urgently asks for any kind
of assistance against the monster
Association noting that the placees in
is completely concealed now because of
the previous carpet bombing child
Emperor estimates that the oxygen in his
space will only last for around 10
minutes so an attempt to make it last
even longer the big brain holds his
breath in hopes for someone to find him
via his transmitter luckily for him
putty PTY prisoner soon comes to his
rescue back over with the extremely
exhausted Joo genos is sadly having all
of his robotic lmbs torn off by a few
blackes yet still when he can the
absolute mad crawls on the ground
carrying the seemingly unconscious
tataki in an attempt to escape from the
countless copies of monsters as
everything seems lost one noise slowly
growing louder and louder symbolizes the
entrance of the planet's strongest man
walking up the hill in front of them
King then appears with his King Engine
already fully rumbling skipping away
from that though back with San student
the Joo continue their fight with G then
taking the stance of the exploding heart
release first a fighting Cell that bang
primarily used before developing water
stream Rock smashing first both bang and
bomb are surprised to see this with bomb
asking his brother how G knew of his
style as bang had sealed it away a long
time ago as then explained through the
old man that go once broke into the safe
that contained the Scrolls of secret
techniques at his dojo and got a grasp
of that specific style even still
despite go using his exploding heart
release first it reminds bang of his own
past self and makes him even more
determined not to lose as soon revealed
that during Bang's past he used to be a
complete Ruffian who would recklessly
challenge any strong opponents and would
often put them in hospital being
disgusted by his brother's brutality bom
decided to confront bang himself and put
an end to his Rampage before they fought
bomb noted that while his brother
thought he'd gained tremendous power he
hadn't really overcome himself and
states that he have to teach bang a
lesson about properly overcoming oneself
the fight then began and shortly after
bomb def deed his younger brother as
bang attempted despite his older brother
bomb just told him to chill out for a
bit before leaving the area this loss
would come to Humble bang over time and
make him see the true era of his ways
through this he chose to create a new
defensive orientated fighting style and
decided to follow his brother's
footsteps by creating his own Dojo
during the years bom would keep an eye
on his brother revisiting his dojo and
smiling with pride at his brother's
changed life back in the present after
recalling his memories about bang and
saying that his brother has been
overwhelmed wed by Go bomb notes that if
bang uses exploding heart release first
then perhaps he can still send a chance
bomb then quickly figures out that bang
won't use it as his brother is slowly
being pushed back though in the fight
it's actually explained that bang feels
like he's getting through to go with his
fist and tells bomb to watch this
carefully he keeps on fighting and
attempts to reach go by using the voice
hidden within the fists as he tries
speaking to go he personally decides
that he will quit being a hero after
this incident is fixed and expresses his
desire of once again being G Sensei
elsewhere in the battlefield homeless
Emperor Reigns a blazing streak of pure
energy down on Ian spring Mustachio and
atomic Samurai the two a Class Heroes
slowly become overwhelmed while Atomic
Samurai is unable to unath his new
weapon he recalls conversing with nitren
over howy sunblade is a telepathic
weapon only un sheath by those it deems
worthy thinking internally Atomic
Samurai then reaches an intense level of
concentration as his mind becomes as
reflective as the surface of water being
able to dispel all of the noise of of
the explosions happening around him and
in that moment the sun blade finally
answers his call instantly Atomic has
his Spirit heavily influenced by the
blade and leaps into the air shredding
apart homeless Emperor's enormous
concentration of energy balls astonished
by this homeless Emperor summons a bunch
more energy orbs and sends them soaring
towards the swordman but to no effect as
the new power of the sun blade easily
stops them just as atomic Samurai is
about to shred the helpless cardr golden
is appears and blocks the killing blow
this sunblade is only able to make a
small ler and golden 's Ultra durable
frame but the second the latter attempts
to break the blade it starts curving at
impossible angles before somehow
managing to cut half of golden is's
right arm clean off having shown its
power the sun blade then sheaths itself
and atomic who's extremely worn out
regains control of his Spirit the evil
natural water monster then shows up on
the Block much to Ian surprise who
thought the monster was completely
eliminated by super Eloy dark shine's
punch just as golden sperm and homeless
Emperor prepar to retaliate a rumbling
sound is heard growing louder from
behind the them turns out that it's the
big man himself King as he makes his way
up behind everyone leaving his enemy
stunned by his magnificent appearance as
the monsters get ready to face the Lone
Hero middle bear arrives on the scene
and initially intends to help King but
then decides to let King handle them all
alone while midle B himself make sure to
keep any of the black is clones from
getting away with all of the heroes
happy that Kings arrived it's Shan that
the strongest man alive looks composed
and confident but within his mind he's
extremely terrified and even regrets is
trying to save JS in the first place
instead of just one or two monsters he
realizes that all of the monsters in
front of him are powerful enough and
they also aren't afraid to face him like
the other monsters have been in the past
standing there all of the black s clones
golden s and homeless Emperor wonder why
King is still not making his move
instead just standing at the top the
hell Bliss asks homeless Emperor
regarding how the famous hero fights
tort two responds that King out of all
of the heroes is the only one he has an
abnormal lack of battle dter on and he
can cause monsters to lose Consciousness
without even touching them telling them
all to not let their guards down even
though they have touched umaki and Jos
as hostages before homeless Emperor
contests King by trying to attack him
with his massive energy sphere King asks
him what if you touched his light ball
which he answers that the hero would be
utterly vaporized in an instant homeless
Emperor proceeds to try and make the
first move but just as he is about to
Tech King advises him that he should pay
attention to the loose rocks under his
feet in order to not fall over homeless
Emperor however mistakenly takes that as
a warning that king would be able to
instantly Dodge his attack and kill him
if he moves left standing there homeless
Emperor is stressed by King but declares
that he will show everyone the real him
hearing this King himself is frightened
and mistakenly believes homeless Emperor
is already aware of him just being a
normal human and because of this he
mutters the words just a regular human
however homeless Emperor hears what he
had to say and after hearing that he
gets even more terrified as he
incorrectly thinks that King has
realized he is nothing more than a
normal human without his light Powers
hus emperor then decides to not let him
talk anymore in order to prevent the
other monsters from finding out his
weakness and attempts to fight King
however before he could launch his
energy sphere zombie man who's been
absent for a while now suddenly emerges
from behind homeless Emperor and grabs
his neck paning him down to the ground
child Emperor who didn't have a clue
where the other S-Class was is delighted
to see that zombie man has managed to
survive while homeless Emperor is left
in a panic and call to Black s to assist
and get the S-Class hero away from him
black is though just doesn't listen to
his fellow monster as he is still so
focused on King standing in front of him
deciding to handle the hero on his own
meanwhile child Emperor sends his
messenger bugs to some of the pris
heroes informing them of his plan of
luring all of the monsters into a
straight line in front of King so that
he can unleash his prolific ultimate
Hellfire burst wave motion Cannon and
eliminate all of them in one go by the
way this is just like obviously a random
move King made up and that everyone has
probably heard through rumors and just
assume that it was like his ultimate
move that he used to destroy things
anyway black is reveals to King that he
also counting golden s currently has a
total of 54 trillion clones and asks the
hero if he can manage to defeat them all
after he finishes talking all of his
clones suddenly charge towards golden a
and begin merging with him while a unit
of a 100 blackish CES is detached as
insurance as the 100 clone unit of black
SES is confronted by middleb it's shown
that black s is actually in tears it's
explained while dodging middleb attacks
that he feels incredible sadness as
trillions of him are being erased as if
they are all fighting for dominance yet
also he is incredibly happy at the same
time because all of them are combining
to form one new being the ultimate
Platinum s marking the moment the TR him
debuts coming back into the scene
randomly again the evil natural water
monster and the new Fusion of clones are
now perfectly lined in front of King
seeing this child empor notifies King
that Jos and tatsumaki have been rescued
and tells him to quickly release his
attack skipping away from King though
until the other fight the intense battle
between go and bang continues with bang
being the one who who is at a
disadvantage but briefly gain him the
upper hand by using his grappling
abilities and kicking Geral away Geral
eventually demonstrates his roaring Aura
skying fist to the shock of both bang
and bomb dting forward he clashes with
bang in a rapid show of insane blows the
intense shock wordss generated from G's
multitude of techniques are so powerful
that they turn everything within the
vicinity into complete powder seeing
this bom remarks that if bang takes a
direct Hur from the hero Hunter he'll
die as the shock wav will course through
and wreck his weak body however bang is
able to effectively avoid the
devastating technique G's throwing at
him until he attempts to land a final
attack of his own on his ex student bang
successfully lces punch into G's face
drawing a noticeable amount of blood
from him and cracking his face well G
simply grazes Bang's cheek but like I
previously mentioned before the shock
wave from his blow is strong enough to
cause a firment of damage to the oldie
causing his former Master to finally
fall defeated after a tough fight bom
expresses his concern over his brother's
condition having seen him fall then
notices that he smiling F ugly as
approaching his brother and is delighted
at the fact that he has finally found
bang to claim his revenge skipping away
from them though and flying over to
platinum S as the ultimate Fusion as
finalizing the transformation and zombie
man is pting down homeless Emperor the
S-Class hero claims to homeless emperor
that not even platinum s can stand a
chance against King stating that their
efforts are futile in front of the
famous Heroes overwhelming strength
homeless empor though responds to him
that King has only been cautious and
observing for the time being he Smiles
with a confidence saying that even a
single black is is strong enough to take
on an A Class Hero and with so many
clones combined their power would be
unimaginable although he claims that the
fusion still isn't as powerful as him
Hess Emperor instead offers zombie man a
quick and painless death as he tells the
hero to let go of him though zombie man
replies that he still has several
questions and starts interrogating the
monster for the true nature of his
powers yet before homeless Emperor is
even able to say anything he sees a
giant figure appear on the moon suddenly
he experiences a vision where he's in a
giant field with God looming above him
suddenly homeless Emperor's Life along
with his light powers are taken away by
God marking his death as his body
disintegrates into salt before zombie
men's eyes back on Earth child Emperor
and atomic Samurai wonder why King as an
unleashing his ultimate Hellfire burst
wave motion cannon in his mind child
emperor deduces that King is still
waiting for his opponent to get to their
best condition to defeat them noting
that it would cause fear to the other
monsters and also act as a deterrent for
future ones
King finally starts unfolding his arms
prompting the other Heroes to think that
he is about to release his attack and
cheer him on suddenly PL Miss extends
the tentacle on his head and attacks
some of the heroes around king and the
blink of an eye incapacitating them as
king stands there frightened with what
just happened Planet Mass tells him that
he knows he has desired a one-on-one
battle with him in this perfect State he
proceeds to challenge King telling him
to unleash his ultimate attack on him
Elsewhere on the battlefield F ugly is
seen standing in front of bang now who's
lying defeated on the ground and wonders
if go is the one who defeated him go
having his skin in his left eye
shattered begins roaring and charging
towards fur ugly and actually manages to
rip a hole through the monster's body
with a kick his King is closing his eyes
and shelting the name of his attack to
intimidate his opponent Geral appears
and proceeds to dash in the direction of
PL mes and sends the fusion flying with
a single Ki realizing that something's
up the evil natural water senses Go's
murderous intent and attacks him with
two water jets only for the hero Hunter
to deflect them both and be pummeling
the water monster with multiple blows
with all of these attacks happening in
like literally the blink of an eye King
wasn't even aware of G's presence and is
taken by shock with what just happened
falling backwards himself King is just
utterly confused about what has just
occurred over with the monsters Fe ugly
as shock at seeing the Fatal injury he
just received before collapsing and
having his entire body Melt Away
standing there and having already
defeated the monsters Gan quickly takes
notice of a wormhole that emerges near
him and releases sight armor fleshy
flesh in manaco who are all seemingly
surprised that they have been teleported
to the surface by blast being one of the
only Heroes left Kang is delighted to
see that s arm has finally showing up
while fleshy flesh observes the
surroundings and wonders if the other
Heroes have all been defeated flesh
quickly realizes the threat of go is
near while saitama rushes over towards
Jos expressing concern about the
Cyborg's bating condition while there
with them Sait goes on to ask Jos ofg as
the one who's responsible for his
destroyed state with Goos responding
that it was actually a monster
Association an executive member having
just regained his senses himself G is
confused about his new form noting that
he does not remember ever surfacing from
underground and honestly was just
dreaming about sparring with bang in the
past to his surprise fleshy flesh
appears out of nowhere throwing a kick
directly at g with him narrowly being
able to dodge it instantly the hero
Hunter recognizes him as the S-Class
hero ranked 13 fleshy flesh who's a
little slow asks him if he's the monster
king boss to which the hero Hunter
answers that he has nothing to do with
the monster Association and reveals to
him that his name is actually G in an
instant Platinum s interrupts them by
simultaneously passing through and
pummeling them both having seen the
change in G he States he's disappointed
as even though he's monsterized so much
he does still not have the courage to
join the monsters both being unfaced by
the sudden attack fleshy flesh and go
start a free battle with Platinum s
allowing the three of them to exchange
extremely powerful blows at incredible
speeds meanwhile King comes up to sight
Arma absolutely terrified and in tears
he goes with to tell him that Jos did a
great job protecting tatsumaki which
Sait then compliments his cyborg for
having heard this the bed bot tells Sait
that he was no longer able to
self-destruct and dire situations and
finally asks his master if he has
actually become stronger responding to
his question simus says that for the
fact that he did not explode means he
has indeed gotten stronger thankful for
how much he's grown Jos appreciates
hearing those words from his master
stating that it was all thanks to sa and
Dr Casino for where he is now elsewhere
the battle between go flashy flesh and
plattinum is generates a geometric
structure of light covering the sky due
to them moving at unimaginably fast
speeds it's mistakenly believed by most
of those who are observing the battle
from afar to actually be the work of
tatsumaki and the other esper with only
a few aware that those are the Sparks of
the battle between flashy flash go and
platinum s during the fight Platinum is
suggests go team up with him to defeat
flashy flash pointing out that the hero
has been wakened due to losing his sword
G being G though pretends to agree with
him but it's as soon as Platinum lets
his guard down he's punched in the face
by the hero Hunter just then G turns at
Upp a notch and begins to Showcase his
monster Calamity God Slayer fist a
fighting style that is a combination of
many martial arts he has learned
throughout battles which as he uses it
against his two foes manages to
overwhelm both flashy flashh and
platinum ear somewhere else deep
underground back with it like mysterious
Shrine is located a bunch of flesh is
seen sticking into its surroundings
while the shadow of a centipede like
creature is seen growing bigger and
bigger in the meantime on the surface a
massive aircraft carrier is operating at
Sea through radar those inside it begin
to notice an immensely huge a mysterious
object is about to emerge right below
them as they prepare to withstand the
impact of it a peer of gigantic eyes
emerged from the ocean below capsizing
the entire aircraft sending men weaponry
and vehicles flying everywhere as the
battle continues elsewhere flashy Flash
starts to get overwhelmed and is just
shocked at the fact that any single day
he has encountered four people who have
surpassed his supposedly unmat speed he
desperately tries to best go and pl a
Miss but fails with him eventually being
defeated by the latter with only two
monsters remaining in this battle now
they resume their accelerated Bel
exchanging a multitude of blows in the
sky with only 1.3 milliseconds before go
then manages to land a stronger hit and
send Platinum es flying into the ground
below as Platinum es quickly gets up and
calls out to go he is finally defeated
by the hero Hunter who instantly phases
through him while delivering a killing
blow that causes him to explode into a
multitude of bits meanwhile tataki
begins to see God in front of her who is
impersonating blast's appearance in
order to lure her into accepting its
powers to be honest like after rereading
like this Arc and everything Mona's
thought is that anyone who accepts these
Powers becomes a porn completely under
the control of the So-Cal God then if
God deems them unworthy after watching
them fight it can take back its powers
and turn them into salt with the person
who had the power subsequently dying in
the process during this Visionary thing
tataki remembers what blasa told her
about not expecting someone to come and
save her she realizes that whoever is in
front of her now is not actually blast
and instead asks to thing in front of
her about its true identity unable to
deceive tatsumaki God simply leaves in
irritation almost instantly after coming
back to reality blast using his
teleportation ability comes up to tataki
worrying about her coming into contact
with the so-called God but to his
surprise he has just left flabbergasted
after she says that she managed to
resist it as blast comments that tataki
has indeed grown a smile on her face
grows with without her being able to
open her eyes due to the lack of
strength that she has left King who's
standing next to him is astonished at
blast sudden emergence s who's nearby
carrying an injured putty PTY prisoner
comes up to them and notices blast as
well calling out to him hearing saam
calling blast as well King and jenus are
surprised that the person they seen is
the top ranked S-Class hero blast talks
to them saying that he was being held up
fighting that thing in a different place
at I guess a similar time he reconvince
King and tells him to protect tatsumaki
saying that he has to and provide backup
somewhere else as Ken questions what he
meant blast steps through another portal
that appears to have multiple people on
the other side and he says that he is
not fighting alone shortly before
teleporting away much to King in my own
Dam's confusion immediately after he
leaves a big earthquake appears with the
source of it being revealed as the sage
centipede who emerges from the deep hole
where tataki had attacked Orochi before
after showing up Sage centipede loudly
claims that it has been sent to destroy
the abnomal fist that opposes God and
declares itself the Incarnation of
Father Earth Sage centipede then directs
its eyes towards the sea where the evil
natural water monster is now known as
the evil ocean water monster now due to
it fusing with the entire ocean Sage
cped refers to the evil ocean water as
the Incarnation of mother ocean stating
that along with the L it will bring
total Destruction to the entire planet
surprisingly though in a pure flash G
jumps forward towards Sage centipede and
Pummel it in the head with a multitude
of different strikes the emergence of
sage centipede and evil ocean water
monster terrifies second guard needle
Star as well as Mizuki all of whom who
want to move away from those two
devastating threats as soon as possible
in the meantime G's combo attacks have
proven to be extremely effective against
Sage centipede who's taken damage and is
stunned by the hero Hunter's assault G
notices that there is a helicopter from
AF far and sees that Tero is inside it
he's surprised that the boy has finally
managed to escape the monster
Association headquarters and taunt Sage
centipede trying to attract its
attention however Sage centipede also
realizes that the helicopter behind it
concerns go and it tells him not to move
otherwise evil ocean water will shoot
down the helicopter with its great
Oceanic Cannon as G is shocked and
annoyed after hearing this Sage
centipede attacks him with it centipede
Grand March surrounding and striking the
hero Hunter repeatedly with evil ocean
water aiding the centipede by shooting a
devastating water Canton at the hero
Hunter King from afar observes the great
destruction caused by evil ocean waters
water cannon while slowly carrying an
injured Touch of Mari to safety having
taken the combined attacks from the
monster G is extremely hurt and launched
a great dis away while Sage centipede
just laughs at his predicament at this
moment Sage centipede then notices
something dashing towards the sea at
lightning speeds leaving powerful shock
waves in its wake The Bean Is revealed
to be sarm who proceeds to jump towards
the evil ocean water and Strikes it with
a single serious punch upon contact the
punch completely dissipates the evil
ocean water monster and splits the
entire ocean behind it shocking the sage
centipede who simply can't even fathom
what the hell just happened the aircraft
carrier which have been completely
enveloped by the ocean begins to
suddenly expose itself catching
saitama's attention due to not having
somewhere to stand saitama is unable to
lift and carry the carrier so instead
man literally uses the vessel's deck as
an impromptu surfboard helping the ship
escape the enormous tsunami waves Sage
centipede has just Liv in pure dis
belief as it thinks evil ocean water
monster is dead after one punch and wers
what on Earth just happened to it it
then pursues the helicopter out of pure
Rage which tiio and wagon Mar are inside
go noticing this and already having
recovered from the damage chases after
the monster suddenly the absolute G
himself middle bat jumps onto the sage
centipede and Strikes it in the face
with a multitude of swings from the bats
however Sage easily shrugs off his
assault and simply tosses him away
skipping away over to G as he boasts
towards the monster trying to save triio
well he actually ends up running into
the falling midal bat leaving the two of
them surprised at seeing each other
again believing him to be get in his way
once more just like the last time they
fought where he was trying to attack
curo but G kept beating him back middle
B attacks the hero Hunter because of
this but he swiftly evades the hero
swings and keeps moving forwards towards
the centipede ignoring him go then jumps
on the centipedes back with middle bat
slowly catching up to him as the two of
them then Chase each other on their way
to the monster's head a reporter
helicopter pops up right above the
center ped annoyed with the news team's
interference Sage cped strikes the
helicopter with one of its antennas
however middle bed appears in front of
the helicopter and blocks it with the
strike well G gets onto the helicopter
and scares off the people inside of it
causing it to fly away from the sand
immediately after saving all of the
humans G charges towards the sage
centipede and lands a barrage of attacks
yet despite taking his blows head on the
centipede is only momentarily knocked
back and quickly recovers from it I
absolutely like love this next moment
here boys together both G and metal bat
stand side by side and assume they're
fighting stances middleb questions
what's wrong with G given that he not
only attack Sage centipede but also
helped the report a helicopter Escape
commenting that now he's even more
sensible than when he was a human
hearing this the absolutely confused G
response by saying that he just wants to
show the world how terrifying he truly
is he informs the hero of the monster's
Target being the rescue helicopter
behind them stating that they two have
to buy some time for it to get away
having thought of a plan G suggests that
middle bat act as a decoy much to the
hero's anger and after a small argument
they finally agree to actually tame up
against the sage centipede meanwhile in
the hero Association hospital suu and
sukko are seen watching the situation in
Z City through a television sukko
comments that there reporters will not
get away from the monster referring to
go that can leap into a helicopter suu
on the other hand expresses that the
helicopter did not crash and he somehow
believes that go did not want to hurt
those people back on the centipede go
and middleb unleash their abilities with
roaring or a sky ripping thirst in
Savage tornado however their attacks
cannot bring down the monster due to its
extreme durability as well as its
powerful raging abilities while
recognizing Go's strength Sage cped
thinks of middle bear as a non-threat
and considers taking him hostage stge G
then criticizes middle B for not being
able to deal any damage to the centipede
like monster and upon hearing the
argument Sage centipede figures out that
it would not work instead it continues
to pursue the helicopter in an attempt
to take the passengers all hostage as
the monster gets closer and closer one
shotter unable to aim properly due to
losing a special mechanical eye shoots
at the centipede but misses Sage
centipede then eventually catches the
helicopter with his antennas shattering
the rotor blades and taking the people
inside hostage at this moment G and M B
both stopped dead in their tracks
realizing the severity of the situation
immediately following this Sage
centipede attacks the two with it
centipede Grand March causing the
terrain around them to erupt seemingly
taking them down du of the damage
sustained G was forced to his knees and
subsequently grabbed by one of the
monsters human arms just as he is about
to be killed by the sage centipede one
shotter now able to aim accurately
thanks to him having support from gear
spear shoots the monster multiple times
directly aiming now at its eyes as the
attack hurts and moment materially
distracts it allowing go to pry open the
hold and escape from the monster's hand
now freed G proceeds to Pummel Sage
centipede with Terror and the other
people around mistaking him for a hero
and cheering him on as G is about to be
attacked he still continuously attempts
to free the helicopter from the monsters
antennas until middle B with a serious
injuries appears and manages to chop off
stage ced's antennas completely
surprising the monster with middle B's
Sudden Change and string as we all know
though since our boy received literally
life-threatening injuries middle B
through his fighting Spirit was pumped
up and his strength has increased to an
even higher degree than before he
informs G who's still holding the
helicopter that about 500 M away there
is a huge safety net hearing this
information the hero Hunter without
second thought then proceeds to throw
the remains of the helicopter to that
safety position much to Sage ced's dis
pleasure the two of them then stand side
by side ready to give the monster all
they have got left Sage coped refus to
their team up as pathetic shortly before
charging at them with it
6,666 League Grand Dr a powerful attack
that obviously resembles a drill in
response gett and middleb working in
tandem utilize their strongest
techniques respectively with G
unleashing another cross Fang dragon
slayer first and middleb with his pumped
up seage Hurricane accidentally created
a combo attack against the giant monster
successfully countering its rush and
even cracking the durable outside shell
muster the shock of the centipede it's
then revealed that middleb is inferior
to go and strength by a large margin and
the current reason the S-Class hero can
keep up with the hero Hunter is because
of their resonance which is amplify
middle BET's capabilities to amazing
levels for those like absolutely
confused on what resonance could be well
when light or sound wave strike an
object that is already vibrating at some
particular frequency so think of like
that as their attacks on the centipede
which is traveling towards them and if
that frequency happens to match that
resonant frequency of the object that's
hitting then you'll get what's called
resonance I could go into like the math
and this and stuff but this video is
already long enough without me
interrupting every 5 minutes like I
usually do it's like 45,000 words at
this point in the script or something
but anyway anyway continuing middle B
and go continue the assault with the
former now being strong enough to damage
Sage centipedes exoskeleton with every
single swing du to him resonating with G
although he is quickly knocked back by
the monster G having his strength also
increased greatly due to him resonating
with middle B is now able to blast
through Sage cop's body and steal its
regeneration core ceasing the monster's
ability to continue regenerating as Sage
is left shocked at the effect that it
can no longer regenerate from damage G
explains that he noticed a certain spot
on the monster that was releasing en and
therefore deduce that it was probably
his core the C ped attempts to take it
back but the hero Hunter throws it
directly up into the sky at high speed
causing the centipede monster to
instantly Chase trying to catch up to
the core down below midle B unable to
continue fighting lies on the ground and
mters that g has to defeat Sage cede
before seemingly becoming unconscious as
a result of his heavy and Drees
Elsewhere on the battle field it's
revealed that sweet mask has somehow
survived being attacked by furer ugly
who had seemingly ripped him in half
before he approaches pegard who he
doesn't recognize at all due to the
ladder losing like his entire fat form
swi Mar then asks pegard what he's doing
here and instead of answering Peg God
just asks him the exact same question
with mask responding that a monster had
ripped his jeans so he needs new
clothing seeing Peg's jacket on the
ground am Stakes it for a tent and uses
it to cover his lower half without the
now skinny S-Class hero minding it am my
mask then demands that he'll take Pig
God to safety but the letter states that
he cannot move now and has to eat
something first before they leave
quickly the skinny man then starts
chowing down on the corpse of gums which
surprises amay after a moment of
thinking amay tells pigard to take here
and simply leaves him alone meanwhile
Sage CIP is trying to catch up to its
regeneration core which was literally
thrown out of the planet by go with the
monster leaving the Earth's upper
atmospheres it's finally able to reach
and get a hold of the core with its
antennas while also having revealed its
true length as it's extended all the way
from the ground to space g having run up
its back leaps at the Regeneration core
before it completely and utterly
destroys the object by jumping down upon
it then continuing to head downwards
towards the stage centipede with a
karate chop G recalls how he first
joined bangs dojo and failed to break up
50 tiles in a single chop leaving only
one left a true Testament to his
capabilities as a newcomer back in
reality with this giant centipede in
front of him it finally meets its end at
the hands of the hero Hunter who chops
it in half vertically all the way down
to the very surface of the planet
standing near back on the ground in
front of the defeated Sage Center PE gal
claims that his fist has now been
perfected over with a confused sweet
mask as he's carrying an unconscious
metal bat he walks over seeing the
massive corpse of sage centipede and
wondering what could have possibly
happened he then notices that Monaco is
trying to wake up a knocked out flashy
flashh but mistakes it for an
assassination attempt so he immediately
attacks her however before he can strike
the monster his punch is intercepted by
a freaking aircraft carrier sliding in
and crashing between them knocking both
sweet mask and middle b as well as
fleshy flesh and man flying away in
different directions meanwhile King
who's still carrying the incapacitated
tatsumaki notices the carrier flying
straight towards him and panics
realizing sight armor is nowhere to be
found as king is standing there
panicking wondering what in the world is
going to do Fuki arrives and
congratulates King on rescuing her
sister it's then explained that she's
arrived with a new blizzard group this
new group of hers consists of tank top
Master spring roasio Bal bang super Eloy
dark shine and niden which I don't know
how she managed to scam them into the
group but know like good on her anyways
it's shown that spring Mustachio is
carrying the chin while tank top Master
is carrying bomb bang and dark shine
King questions who the guy wearing a
tank top is but then soon realizes the
one wearing a tank top is obviously tank
top master who now looks much F than he
did before despite being fat now tank
top master has actually gained a
tremendous amount of strength seeing her
sister Fuki then rushes towards her
saying that she will give some of her
energy to touch Mari spring Mustachio
questions if that's safe as Fuki has
already used up most of her energy on
healing the other Heroes yet the team
leader just yells at him to be quiet
Fuki then says if she could heal his
sister even a little bit then tataki
might be able to get all of the heroes
out of the area via her telekinesis
knowing that she doesn't have the
strength to actually save her sister
though Fuki asks tank top Master to lend
her a hand standing there tank top
Master thinks about tataki for a moment
and refusing to accept her death before
his Mastery of tank top wearing
surpasses her psychic powers decides to
help her getting all fired up he tells
them all to not bite their tongues it's
for spooky already used a bunch of her
energy on healing the other Heroes so
instead King's urge to LEAP a top the
deck and save everyone else quickly in
response though Kang comes up with the
excuse that the shock waves produced
from his King style super catch might
harm the injured so it would probably be
better to use psychic powers however in
that moment King truly sees his golden
ticket out of the situation as looking
up towards the ship's deck he notices
that no one other than S armor would
already be on the ship in control of it
and in sait's mind the man had come to
the conclusion that this was the perfect
place to park the boat thinking and
literally having balls of steel King
with his big brain simply tells all of
the other Heroes to hold on and not move
at all as they would be perfectly fine
if they didn't move nobody like really
understood what was going on but they
all did as they were told believing in
King's plan meanwhile up on the ship s
Hammer shifts positions then walks in a
slow relaxed manner of Elsewhere to yet
again and Beed his boot into the deck of
the ship throwing a massive twist into
the ship's lumbering movement everyone
King included was absolutely blowing
away way and an utter disbelief at the
ship's changing speeds but scammer
wasn't even done yet once he regains his
footing man literally leaps away with an
unreal degree of force causing the ship
to crumble away from the shock waves
alone caused by the jump the crumbling
ship which was now effectively embedded
in the ground is shown to even be at an
angle that it would redirect the ocean's
water right over the heroes leaving them
completely unharmed this luck of their
would get even crazier as not only did
the ship protect them from the Fallout
of the evil ocean water monster but it
also protected them from being crushed
by the corpse of s cede which is still
having its long body fall from the sky
above as the r seemingly alive after
this tank top Master thanks King for
making his decision as if they didn't
follow King's orders they would have
been dead either way Fuki then notes
that they can't stay here either because
the water has begun to rise and now
they're at threat of actually drowning
Pig God now having regained his fat body
suddenly arrives and does like the most
big brain play of his life flies through
a wave and puts all of the heroes
including nurin and bomb into his mouth
to save them meanwhile G looks on at his
surroundings wondering what in the world
happened to the evil ocean water monster
in that moment saama finally appears
behind go and asks who he is supposed to
be although go at this point doesn't
realize sat's actual identity he still
answers the Bold King's question
regarding what he is by stating that he
is a Monster who will cast all of
humanity into the depths of Despair and
become absolute evil saama is confused
though about whether go is evil
considering he helped hel opter escaped
from the sage centipede just before but
G reasons that he needs witnesses to
spread fear and to let people know that
he is stronger than any hero or Monster
stating that absolute evil correlates
with absolute strength G then tells saam
to leave and quit his job as he will
annihilate both the monster and hero
Association he then and our typical evil
villain stereotype Rambles on about his
plans of utter domination after
listening to G sa begins to leave
without acknowledging him as a monster
which leaves e jacked up Garo just
utterly confused frustrated saitama
explains to him that the only reason he
is out here in the first place is
because he went out of his way to
complain about the noise and now because
of that his house has been completely
destroyed due to this random set of
circumstances and sait's eyes he's
extremely upset and says that now he
would rather blow up the entire planet
making G shiver with his words as Sait
leaves G calls out to him saying he'll
pay should he underestimate absolute
evil and charges at him with a punch
unfortunately for him saitama is just
frankly unbeatable and with an impulsive
punch he knocks G back before the latter
could land the hurts after being punched
G manages to remember saama identifying
him as the one board guy that he's run
into several times before which is like
obviously just hilarious to me I love
how like all the past scuffles or
interactions I don't know really what
you would call them between like go and
Sarma have just been go getting
completely and utterly abused by an un
side hmer like it's it's just too good
anyway anyway now the main battle can
begin as go finally realizes who this
goat of a Baldi truly is now having
recovered from s Hammer's punch gup
appears to probably begin fighting him
they begin exchanging blows while
crossing kilometers in just moments
reaching far into the upper atmosphere
of the sky sa attacks G with a punch
aimed at his head but G now having
literally ascended manages to dodge it
before a kicking Ali into the ground
causing a huge section of land mess to
instantly rupture sending Rubble
shooting out when s stands up onto his
feet G leaps down towards him with a
hand chop striking his head directly
causing a forceful impact on the
surroundings however the hand chop is
not enough to phas our boy who
retaliates with a simple headbutt that
shedders G's forearm despite this G
manages to regenerate his forearm and
attempts to punch scammer however the
cape BDI is faster and manages to punch
him back first after being knocked back
a considerable Distance by sight hmer
G's body and response to his anger under
goes a mutation that increases his size
and stature as well as his strength at
this moment tario remember that like
little we of a kid who was a mad hero
fan had the whole book and all well like
now he's just a mad G Fanboy at this
point in the stories which is like dope
and all cuz like so is everyone else
obviously but anyway anyway just before
this point somehow he had managed to
evade all of the other Heroes trying to
flee and made his way up behind the
bulked up demonic gero he then tells him
that he is a hero to him which annoys go
who tries to explain again to tario that
he is not a hero at all yet even after
what G says the boy still insists that
he is the greatest hero to him and tells
go to stop pretending to be a monster
saama slowly comes up to the two of them
and comments on the Terrible Things G
has done like murking Heroes crushing
dojos and now playing Monster causing
this innocent kid to break down and cry
as Sait takes his steps towards the hero
Hunter tiio tries to to stop him from
further fighting the hero however G
still lays outside and punches him hard
in the head after getting provoked
though as per usual sa is completely
unscathed even after taking a punch head
on he then boldly and like the true
charad level bold King he is reassures a
shocked tiio that go will not be able to
hurt him angered G tries to kick sa but
is immediately slapped Away by the hero
as if it was nothing back with Hario sa
asks him if he'd like him to stop but
not kill go and return him to normal to
which go solemnly nods in agreement
which is like so damn wholesome man I
love seeing these little bits of like
actual human moments from our psychotic
little Baldi it it just goes to show
that he still has a bit of heart LIF in
him somewhere so finally it's just the
two big bad boys standing there and S
him of questions why go is acting like a
monster despite previously having helped
Heroes G tries to reason that he was
merely using them to further his goals
of absolute evil yet after Sait casually
lumps Go's absolute evil together with
world peace in a randomly coincidental
way go angrily charges at him he manages
to Parry a punch from saitama then using
the momentum he hand chops him right in
the side of his face and lands a punch
to his head before elbowing him in the
stomach all done within the fraction of
a second when sa grabs Go's arm the
enlightened hero Hunter performs several
lock on moves that eventually hit s arm
in the her go instantly follows up and
proceeds to use his God Slayer instant
attack slamming his foe into the ground
with a flurry of monstrous punches
however Sait having evaded the attack
soon emerges nearby after digging
underground and throws a massive rock at
go while asking the hero Hunter if he's
able to avoid his punches due to his
special martial arts skills to which G
confirms while shattering the rock with
his freaking jointless rotating arms go
attempts a barrage of attacks on saama
but the hero manages to dodge prompting
him to remark that sarm has amazing
reflexes and Agility but still skill and
has plenty of openings which is just
hilarious like G bro you need to focus
on yourself first claiming to be able to
read all of sait's moves now beg brain G
declares that the hero will lose due to
his lack of technique and being a
complete amateur before sending him
absolutely flying and crashing into
several buildings with this Gods Slayer
ascending attack instantly after this
like just unfathomable feat G catches
right up to S armor and uses his great
fuding which like I hope I got right and
didn't mess it up like cuz this Tech is
just absolutely insane I'm going to be
calling out the art for this entire
video cuz it's just freaking Gods here
at this point like look at it the
buildings lift up and then slam together
like it's so so good and believe me this
is just the freaking beginning of the
stuff this great fuding since the big
Baldi crashing through more buildings
lifting them up off the ground and
ultimately pulverizing them into nothing
but dust and smoke believeing here as
one now G states that scammer may have
incredibly tough skin and bones but he
cannot train his internal organs which G
believes to have been damaged by his
attack however to his surprise Sait
emerges completely unharmed it is then
shown that go and destroying the
buildings and following in the way of
absolute evil has accidentally saved
five hero Association staff members who
had been trapped inside an underground
shelter as all of them show their
gratitude to him before leaving saitama
ironically comments on how absolute evil
is actually good at saving people
enraged that he just ain't evil enough
yet G attacks saitam again and soon
evolves even further taking on this sick
as demonic type form that has these
almost unproportionate looking Wings on
his back but it's honestly still fire as
while defending against an onslaught
from him saitama states that g has
improved a little which angers the hero
Hunter who with a punch knocks him into
a currently exploding volcano G
immediately charges at sarm and Strikes
him with both of his open Palms causing
the mountain behind to shatter due to
the powerful impact after the attack G
is on his knees and panting while an
unharmed sarmer simply punches him away
recovering his balance G is impressed
that s could withstand the attack that
destroy the volcano behind him also
hilariously following in the current
course of things go has accidentally
saved an entire city from being
destroyed by the volcano's lava and
again sa notices this random act of
so-called kindness and almost taunt him
commenting that g has a great Hero's
instinct which reminds him a lot of King
G CRS two more arms and continues his
Onslaught however he is now visibly
showing signs of panic as he fights back
against our Baldi PS shout out to all
your bald Kings out there like get this
video to 50K likes honestly don't even
know why I'm saying this right now which
is honestly unachievable for me and I'll
go bold like it man I'll B hell why
not I'll do it for do it for 100k subs
and if this video gets to 50K likes I'll
do it cuz hell s armor is a goat man and
I love this Arc so much if it's so much
fun reading it despite being attacked by
the hero Hunter who is using all four
his arms sa effortlessly manages to
dodge and parries a flurry of G's
punches with only one hand while also
telling him to just straight up stop
fighting which is a freaking insane burn
on him man afterwards go places two of
his hands on saarma and takes a form
that resembles a jet while his remaining
two arms emits energy to act as
propulsion hi follows up with a mighty
attack called Extreme Faron G pushes
side Hammer into the ground creating an
intense seismic wave that passes
directly through the Earth's core the
attack is so freaking immensely powerful
that it distorts the SpaceTime around
the Earth moves oceanic plates and even
makes an entire continent raise up from
the other side of the planet it even
messes with the magnetic and
gravitational fields of the planet
putting it as a whole at risk despite
all of his effort saam is still unfaced
by Go's Earth altering attack and
retaliates with his Infamous consecutive
normal punches as the two of them return
from Earth's depths G tries to fend off
sa's flurry of punches but fails at this
moment he recalls the Abominable fist
Sage centipede had once mentioned and
uces that he was referring to sight
Hummer instead of go himself our bald
King proceeds to punch go directly in
the face snapping him back to reality
while causing him to crash through
several mountains and eventually fall
into a massive puddle as he slowly gets
back up G was shocked and angered by
saam's overwhelming power viewing him as
the embodiment of unfairness which like
he literally is like I'm sorry Goku fans
but this is why scammer is unbeatable
like full stop the dude is created to
never lose in the first place Goku has
lost the gu's even freaking died saitam
is literally God at this point his
Insanity incarnate it's like utterly
beautiful and Unstoppable I freaking
love it man because of this G charges
that saitama with a punch refusing to
lose to him however sa punches go before
he came himself and send him flying away
destroying Go's monster form and
exposing this true human body that had
been buried inside his monsters
exoskeleton as go laments being beaten
by such unfairness he hears a voice
calling out to him the voice tells him
that there is only one fist that can
counter the fist that is turned against
God everyone's favorite villain then
sees an apparation of bang hovering
above him and offering go his hand at
the same time massive storm clouds
appear revealing like I don't even know
what to call this thing like God's
leagues or something all we know is this
creature is a 100% on League day right
now anyway with everyone witnessing this
so I ominously Nots that something is
coming in that moment he sees go leap
down from behind to face him once again
sa exclaims that go changed costumes
again while go having received the power
from the one they call God replies that
the only way to counter the fist that is
turned against God is the fist of God
itself like oh my God this form is so
freaking clean like marada you need to
chill man I'm actually going to anyway
anyway now appearing as a void of stars
and galaxies and as new aw
G Cosmic fear mode he takes a fighting
stance and prepares for another round
against the one and only Invincible hero
having now gained the knowledge of all
of the flow of energy that courses
through the universe as well as the
behavior of the forces of the cosmos G
utilizes seed flow of energy to send a
cataclysmic attack towards sight armmer
called the life eradication fist Mark
nuclear fishion the attack results in a
massive nuclear explosion which is
instantly followed by several more that
reach up into the sky as G continues
attack while the surviving Heroes
including psychos who has emerged since
her defeat at the hands of tatsumaki
steering amazement and horror at the
nuclear blasts exploding nearby well
anyway I think it's kind of sad for Our
Heroes Down Below guys time for the
radiation poisoning big rip on them all
down there the heroes below watch the
battle between saitam and go which is
obscured by mountainous clouds from G's
attacks leaving only the Silhouettes
briefly visible through flashes of power
despite the enormous force behind the
attacks saama was much more concerned
over his outfit which leaves go utterly
bewildered nevertheless G proclaims that
he feels like he can do anything before
explaining to sa that in martial arts
there are secret techniques known as
shakai where martial artists can borrow
the power of nature by imitating the
movement of living things G prefers to
address them as modes since to him they
sound cooler that way he then
demonstrates one of these modes that
being Mo saama as saam's own face
appears in place of G featureless
void-like face G duplicates and utilizes
saam's consecutive normal punches
assaulting the hero with his own
technique prompting sa to respond with
his own consecutive normal punches
honestly this is somehow just the
beginning of the true Insanity which is
about to come like hold on to your damn
seats cuz we are going far out of this
freaking world their fists Collide an
exchange of blows creating an enormous
destructive force that pushes out around
them destroying everything in its path
the exchange of blows ends with Sait and
G simultaneously Landing a blow to one
another's faces sending them both
directly into the water below instantly
they both leap back out of the water
with go then taunting saitama on how he
must be at a loss for words upon finding
someone who could finally match his
strength saitam though is slightly
dismayed as he thinks back to how he
promised tario he wouldn't get scratched
seeing this and feeling empowered go
goes to show tario how powerless Heroes
truly are he begins to charge his body
as it is in case in a singularity before
unleashing another extremely powerful
attack called the life eradication fist
Mark Gamay burst towards Sarma okay okay
okay like I'm just going to physically
break open the power scaling world for
one punch man like right here so this
Gamay burst is literally like one of the
most powerful phenomena in existence
like we get this in our own reality we
have evidence Earth was hit by one
during the 7th Century ad but it was
only like a little bit of Gam ation
people wouldn't have noticed it back
then and it was like around 4,000 light
years away from Earth which is an
unfathomable amount of distance if this
Gamay burst happened within a few light
years or even a few hundred light years
which is like by the way still an
unfathomable distance it would rip apart
our atmosphere like instantly and
subsequently kill all life on the
freaking planet now get this okay like
like get this this game Reb burst is on
the surface of this freaking planet with
people right next to it like they they
should be vaporized instantaneously
along with the planet like they
shouldn't even be there nothing should
be there as soon as that ability goes
out but like the fact they even there
right now makes them naturally the
strongest people and the strongest soil
in existence like in anime full stop
like show me another damn Series where a
plain a grade type hero is able to stand
next to a force that would kill all life
within a fraction of a second of it
happened at the moon's distance from our
own Earth anyway anyway I've rambled on
for too long I'm just nerdy as for that
science stuff I absolutely love it now s
realizes that if any attack grazes the
ground it would destroy the planet so in
an attempt to save it he decides to jump
high into the air to bring the attack
away from the ground however G thinks he
is attempted to dodge it by jumping
because of this the attack directly hits
and completely engulfs sight armor in a
beam of the universe's highest level
radiation sending him off the planet at
literally the speed of light itself if
not faster because that is literally the
speeds we are talking about here when a
gam ra burst goes off man's ability can
technically go faster than light itself
self now with big baly literally shot
into the abyss of space g lands on a
pile of debes and confronts the various
Heroes of the hero Association that have
huddled around together the remaining
Heroes immediately realized that the man
standing before them was the source of
this massive energy explosion just
moments before only the S-Class Heroes
remain on the Spot while the lower ranks
begin to run away in fear seeing this G
questions if he has finally achieved his
ultimate goal of becoming absolute evil
grateful for the strength he had
received go looks into the sky and
ominously says thank you bang being one
of the heroes who chose to stay rather
than run away confronts go and asks if a
monster did something to him G then
reveals to bang that he wasn't truly
tricked by The Entity that approached
him earlier and instead knew all along
that the strange figure who took the
form of bang wasn't actually his former
Master regardless G was informed that
simply coming into contact with the
entity was enough for him to be greatly
influenced by it however G denies that
he has become a puppet and states that
what he is doing is of his own free will
after making this clear to everyone go
decides that it is now time to conduct
evil as go approaches the remaining
Heroes child Emperor and Wan Mar start
to bleed from their noses moments later
the two children collapse onto the
ground seemingly dead to the effects of
G's radiation despite G stating that he
is in control of his own actions bang
still believes that there is something
Evil Within go and that that evil is now
controlling him suddenly oh yes man the
big man himself rank one S-Class hero
blast randomly teleports into the area
and introduces himself to a surprised go
he attempts to raising with go staing
that he has been controlled by a
mysterious entity no one is God and
emphasizes that in Go's current form any
attack Unleashed would endanger all life
on Earth although go still retains his
keyless demeanor he is somewhat
intrigued by what Blast has just said
and asks what he should do about it
blast offers to transport go into
another dimension but the awaken G
simply declines the offer and instead
boasts about how as mere presence is now
causing people to die believing that he
has finally become the true symbol of
fear bang attempts to stop G from
proceeding but suddenly Goos who's
literally nothing but a damn torso at
the moment uses his the remaining bits
of power he has left and hurs himself
towards the seemingly Invincible enemy
and headbutt him in the chip stating
that there is another radiation
resistant hero he forgot about however
though G easily grabs the hero by the
hair and goes to finish him off but
before he can do anything blast
intervenes and begins to fight gal off
himself blast fires his di mentioned
Cannon towards go but the hero Hunter
quickly Dodges the blast will coming te
it to be a lame attack which is you know
kind of funny because of all the hype
around blast you'd expect him to have
these insane abilities but he's just got
like these boxing gloves pretty much
however a portal appears above G and
transports him to where blast is
followed by a powerful punch from blast
called the gravity knuckle straight to
G's face forcing him to release Goos
blast summons another portal to where go
is and redirects his trajectory to have
him meet yet another punch straight to
the face blast continues this pattern as
he rapidly pumes G in the face all the
while slowly bringing his portals closer
together before long blast quickly seals
the two portals with the intent of
sealing go within another dimension
however much the blast shock emerges
from a portal of his own making having
mimiced blast's own powers and
techniques he now wields blast's gravity
knuckle in his right hand and his own
life eradication fist Mark nuclear fion
in the other he uses both of these to
unleash a rapid barrage of attacks on
blast doing his best to try and
overwhelm the number one hero the forces
blast on the defensive as he summons
multiple teleportation rings to redirect
G's attacks elsewhere another portal is
then summoned by blast above the sky
which absorbs the remaining explosions
in order to prevent further destruction
to the environment nonetheless the utter
force of the attack sends both G and
blast shooting away from each other
noting the extreme energy being put off
blast fears that if this battle
continues for much longer then not only
will the gates that seemingly keep God
at Bay weaken but everything on the
planet will die from the radiation G as
a Meine which by the way I like I'm
hella curious as to what these Gates
could be and how like the hell can we
even get to a bigger level of power from
this point my Lord G commends blast as
he sees that he's not the number one
hero for nothing but also immediately
realizes something else and decides to
shift his Focus back onto saama
realizing that the Bold King will soon
return and that the hero was not going
all out while fighting earlier G decides
to kill Jos in order to draw out the
full power of site armor go then
probably the most heart-wrenching moment
in the entire Series so far impales Jos
through the chest and rips out his core
only a a second or two later as go holds
his heart in his hand sa finally returns
back to Earth as he stands there in pure
be weldment and shock a black liquid
slowly begins to pour down like rain due
to the nuclear fallout seeing his dead
pan expression G taunts him by throwing
genus's depleted core at him so catches
it and stars blankly remembering genos's
previous words about how he is always on
time denying them by stating that he is
usually always
late Sait enraged and with a serious
expression on his face unleashes his
first serious punch towards go who
immediately responds with a serious
punch of his own having copied scammer
once again using mode scammer blast
immediately and fearfully realizes that
the Fallout from the two colliding
attacks will completely destroy the
Earth in an attempt to try and save the
planet he summons a portal beneath the
two and just as the fists Collide they
are transported way up in a space above
the upper atmosphere of the earth
however the kinetic energy that erupted
from this serious punch squid was so
powerful that blast's dimensional gate
was unable to sustain it as blast comes
to the realization that he may be unable
to angle the vector of energy away from
all three of blast's allies come to his
Aid which honestly cracks me up man like
who who are these space who are these
space ass looking Ranger goons no I love
the universe expansion stuff for the
next Ark and so forth it's it's great I
can't wait to see like more of this kind
of anyway with all four of them
there they able to create an opening
inside of the barrier that launcher
sight armor and G 43 light minutes away
from the earth while the shock wave of
energy itself is directed in the
completely opposite direction which
results in the destruction of like
thousands and thousands and thousands of
numerous star systems seen in the sky
which is like literally mental like I
don't know where this beam went but it
was probably faster than light itself
and it's probably gone and out the damn
Galaxy by now okay so the final real
battle properly begins now like you guys
this is it this is the end we're getting
to the very end part of the battle this
is insanity incarnate sa and G crash
into a celestial satellite revealed to
be low one of Jupiter's moons the two
were initially bewildered and confused
but After figuring out their location
saama stands above go at top a small
hell and proclaims that he can finally
let loose against someone who can
finally withstand his full power yet
despite that fact he still doesn't feel
the least bit excited to finally go all
out G still annoyed with the current
location suggests that they should find
a way to get back to Earth but Sait
instantly shuts him down and says that
they will need to figure it out after he
defeats them stating that he only needs
one hand to do so and phased go
initiates the fight Once More by simply
summoning a portal beneath s Hammer only
for the Caped body to casually kick it
away much to G's surprise then suddenly
in an instant G is rocked by a punch
from scammer seing them flying off the
moon go quickly creates a portal that
brings them back to scammer and attempts
to counter with a punch only for Sight
armor to flip G's portal upside down
thus making g h the ear instead before
he is then thumped by yet another punch
that sends a rocketing into the floor
unimpressed sa tells go to stop using
his Cosmic tricks and fight him with his
fists going on to taunt him asking if
these attacks are as soall ultimate
martial arts again with the martial arts
Arrow offended by his taunt obliges
while saying he has absorbed countless
martial arts in techniques before he
dashes around Sama with a mint speed
through multiple portals in an attempt
to disorientate him he first detects him
with roaring a sky repping fist then
deflects a punch from s armor with water
streaming Rock smashing fist before
sending the hero flying with exploding
heart to release fist followed by
Whirlwind iron cutting fist then finally
ending the combo with nuclear fision
gravity knuckle that creates a massive
atomic explosion which is then absorbed
into a singularity by the gravity
knuckle standing amidst the smoke G
declares that his fists are unavoidable
and that timing is irrelevant regarding
his attacks but to his shock saama once
again emerges completely unscathed say
for obviously being completely naked
this time as his costume was completely
and utterly destroyed from G's attacks
and as he stands there he replies to the
hunter that he can do something very
similar our bold King the God himself
demonstrates this by digging his fingers
into the ground with one hand like let
me remind you with one hand and
unleashes a new attack called serious
table flip before flipping massive
amounts of the moon's crust thousands of
meters up into the air taking G with it
the attack then utterly decimates the
entirety of the freaking Moon itself un
reveling it like an orange peel or wgo
aimlessly and helplessly hurdles High
into the air amongst the innumerable
number of debris suddenly s dashes
around go with Incredible speed creating
hundreds of after images in the process
before he directs his after images and
himself towards go simultaneously with
another serious series called
omnidirectional serious punch G
instantly avoids the attack by jumping
into a portal only to see much to his
horror that s is already directly below
him within his own portal he had just
freaking open and proceeds to punch him
with a serious punch as the hit lands it
sends flying and Roche of the slabs of
Stone only for saitama to follow up once
again and punch him away as he is about
to hit another slab Sait dashes around G
back and forth with a measurable speed
or while punching him across the
entirety of the demolished surface of
the Moon creating a full-on geometric
surface of light from the intensity of
the attacks G then furiously repels sy's
flurry of attacks with his water stream
Rock smashing Fist and lands on a large
slab of debris go attempts to regain his
composure while needing to find a way to
get above the Rock he creates a portal
only to have his head smashed into
another slab of rock stunned G realizes
that sait's attack had completely warped
his sense of direction and now he
utterly feels like a caged insect being
played with by a child before he could
react he suddenly attacked by another
serious punch from sa G is aasted by
saam's Limitless strength but remains
steadfast and declares that if he is to
win against him then he will need to
continuously replicate his power and
technique until he achieves Victory as
he does this he once again enters mode
sight Hammer before he and the Caped
Baldi both punch each other directly in
the face the battle continues as gal
throws a punch through a hyperspace
portal that reaches sight Arma on the
other end only for Sight armor to
quickly retaliate with a punch of his
own instantly as he is sent hurling
backwards from saam's punch G creates
another portal behind him that redirects
him behind scam and uses his momentum to
unleash an X kick onto sy's head only
for the latter to simultaneously counter
with a punch to G's GS the punch sends
go back into the portal where the hero
Hunter then opening another portal and
swiping back at scammer only to miss as
our bold King jumps backwards he lands
onto a large slab of debris then leaps
downwards with such an immense force
that it destroys the slab and follows
with a monstrous karate trop straight to
g's neck which in turn devastates the
surrounding area around them the fight
escalates as they move and dash about
the decimated moon in an exchange of
vicious blows G is bewildered at the
fact that despite countering him with
just as much power C simply responds
with even greater force than before and
yet I remind you again with just one
hand as well as go performs a powerful
punch to saitama's gut the L doesn't
Flinch encounters with an uppercut that
sends go flying into the air it is then
explained through this shocked go that
saam's growth in power and strength
continuously Rises at an exponential
rate with his own strength struggling to
keep up leading him to realize that at
this rate he could actually die from one
of saitama's punches saam strink SS due
to an upsurge of emotion from him trying
to kill Jos earlier go now slowly
falling behind dashes around with
Incredible speed preparing for an attack
saitama meanwhile only realizes that now
his costume had been completely blown
off and it actually started to get cold
an enraged go attempts to throw a punch
at saitama but the Bold King casually
grabs it without even looking due to the
cold saitama was about to sneeze which
forces go to instinctively evade and
honestly he's goddamn lucky he chose to
as t unleashes a serious sneeze that not
only Parts a large portion of the moon's
floating de breeze but also utterly
annihilates and clears an enormous mass
of Jupiter's atmosphere and weather
system revealing the small supposedly
solid surface of the planet like this is
actually so insane the utter mass that
is on that planet is ridiculous in
actual reality we don't even know if
this surface exists we haven't even a to
get something down there I have no idea
how to even scale the force of this
ability like it's so freaking
unfathomable to me it's that insane the
Display of Power leaves go in shock all
the while they rocket away from the Moon
and Jupiter due to the force of saam
sneeze as they saw through space g
notices the sun then using his enhanced
vision and perception he is able to make
out a Clear Vision of the earth which
allows him to teleport there just before
doing so in an attempt to escape he
threw a nuclear fision punch directly at
Sama giving him the opportunity to
escape and finally return to Earth via
his portal after escaping G celebrates
his return and presumes Victory only to
instantly discover to his horror that
saama was already right behind him
complimenting his last move bewildered G
questioned sa on how he managed to
return to which sa replies by saying
that the coldness of space had given him
such a stomach ache and while he was
initially holding it in G's last attack
surprised him and made him literally
himself back through G's portal as
the fight now kicks back off saama
punches G directly in the face and sends
the two rocketing back down towards
Earth surface as they crash land Al's
punch shatters G's mode sight Hammer
leaving him with his normal human face
now appearing battered and bruised
seemingly defeated now go asks why saama
won't kill him our hero responds that it
is because he is a hero and in addition
to that it was also taro's final request
to stop him without killing him G pauses
when he hears the words final request
and sadly as he looks over to his side
he sees Trio's dead body who had
succumbed to the radiation earlier on G
screams in utter dispear but quickly
attempts to run away upon realizing that
it was too close to tario but stumbles
and falls to the ground seeing taro's
dead body as well as the Earth's
desolate landscape goo sorrowfully
realized that he indeed is that ominous
future saam is standing there only
wonders why G has been acting so strange
ever since he first appeared in his
Cosmic fear mode which you know for
those who are confused confused is like
the moment that the god bang mofo showed
up and gave him some power I guess
curious so asks if someone truly did
make him the way he is now but gett only
solemnly replies that if that is the
case then it was because his Spirit was
weak I Honestly Love G's character
development throughout this fight and
just the series in general it's really
really really really good and I
recommend anyone just to go back and
read the entire point from the moment he
comes in because he's like the main
character from that moment to like
probably right up till now go continues
to dispear as he sees that if he cannot
beat saitama then he can never truly
become absolute evil even so G would
have been satisfied if saama killed him
the way he envisioned Heroes killed all
of their villains and that way his
legacy of being true evil would linger
onward moreover he only meant to save
the likes of tario with his ideals but
tit Cuts him off and says that go only
clung to tario for support was prepared
to angrily retort but upon seeing that
saama was still holding on to Genesis
core he realized that even him with all
of his insane power and strength still
needs something that would help him hold
on to reality and keep fighting when
Sait asks scar what he's going to do now
go somly asks sarm for a favor the favor
involves go wanting sarm to copy his
martial art knowing that Sy will be able
to use them to their fullest potential
with his Limitless power G will pass on
his most powerful martial arts technique
which he has not performed even with
God's power at his disposal so I guess
with all of my Ming on like the martial
arts it's a cheeky one that saves the
day saitama then agrees and gup appears
to transfer his ultimate technique to
saitama as he knows that he would be the
only person able to resist God using its
own power suddenly the one they call God
silences G and begins to siphon his
power and life which subsequently begins
to make G's body break down into salt
which is like kind of random man like
why salt as go fully transfers the
cosmic rays within himself into Sama he
says his final words to the Caped Baldi
stating that he is the only one who can
truly defeat the impending ominous
future that is awaiting him before he
fully perishes and his body crumbles
into salt okay takamichi please sit down
now we got sa time traveling back for
his besty as time travels backwards in
time sa sees all of the instances of
their battle and has left in utter
amazement at the beauty of G's technique
when he spots the moment when go
declares himself as that ominous future
to the heroes of the hero association
saama takes this as his cue and punches
through it back in reality as G looks at
the sky thanking the god that had just
given him the strength randomly and
literally out of freaking nowhere
saitama appears and thumps G with an
infinitely strong hook to his freaking
Dome as explained that because of the
insanity of the training s's punch under
Wi on the moon it had gifted him the
ability to technically reverse time and
thus land his strike before it even
released and reverse causality is
impossible to dodge thus it was not one
punch that decided to fight no it was a
zero punch as the present Heroes watch
in amazement a shocked G realizes that
his power is beginning to escape his
wounded body so yeah like if anyone is
like how the is he able to go from not
dying from one of saam's attacks to just
randomly dying from like a punch
obviously it was the infamous zero punch
we literally like revers time with it
and everything but pretty much saarma is
just like physically something else now
like he's way past go before his Moon
buff so you can imagine what the side is
like now heading go who doesn't even
have like the moon buff of strength from
growing like during the fight anyway the
future s is then instantly pulled
towards his past self and after they
make contact they become one with the
soul side Hammer now holding genus's
core from the future confused as to what
happened saitama only recalls being hurt
by G's Gamay burst which is kind of sad
I wish saitama kind of like remembered
everything or like somewhat remembered
everything but you'll see what in a
second as he looks down he is initially
shocked to see himself holding the
depleted core of his best boy Jos in his
hands he instantly receives an even
greater surprise when he sees a hole in
his costume exactly in the location
where his 12 in King level siiz snake is
at again and just like in the previous
timeline but not aimed at go sa his Ram
by Jos as he flies forward with the last
of his gas once finally back together
the disciple apologizes for getting
carried away but sa is instead surprised
to see him still alive and okay after
losing his power from God through saam's
punch G finds himself weakened and
surrounded by several Heroes Sait and
junos sitting nearby discuss the core
the former is holding junus decides to
plug the caught and to himself to verify
its authenticity but becomes overwhelmed
by its data as it literally having
traveled through time was s displays all
of the pivotal moments from the battle
to him such as all of the hero's deaths
du to G's radiation his own demise at
the L's hands and sa's battle on iO Jos
gathers himself and asserts that the
court is indeed his but from another
timeline Jos asks Sait if he can
remember anything from beforehand
believing that the court and her had
both come from the future either way Jas
proceeds to explain the hypothetical
belief regarding a possible parallel
world or theoretical universe surmising
that the core had possibly come from an
alternative timeline due to saitama's
actions he states that though it is
unknown how the Divergence and different
times had happened it can be confirmed
that there was a new saitama that had
separated from the original who has time
traveled and now has merged with the
past saitama and the current timeline he
notes that the timing of the separating
and merging may be a clue to what point
in the time the Two Worlds had separated
Jus Goes On by stating that in the
future the court had arrived from he was
destroyed by go astounded by what he had
learned from the core Jos believes that
possible parallel worlds do exist even
in the worst possible scenario of his
and many other Heroes Collective deaths
sa's capability to transcend and
manipulate the laws of causality is an
escapable proof of his selfless Flawless
heroism as Jos tries to relay his theory
on how he could have possibly traveled
through time sa is overwhelmed by the
long explanation and does not follow
what the cyborg said at all much less
even comprehend what he is saying to him
ultimately genosis pleased that in order
to save everyone sa transcended time and
face itself so I'm sorry Goku people but
give me a moment where Goku has transed
time and space to win a fight cuz I
ain't seen it elsewhere tiio suddenly
gets up awakened by a vision of G before
it fades away sitting there he hears a
Ruckus nearby and walks over to it
closing in he sees some of the lower
ranked Heroes bating up an injured G who
offers no resistance midle B steps in
and demands that they stop li sweet mask
mentions on how G had gone berserk
earlier and that g will kill them if
nothing is done to him angered the aass
hero proclaims that as a monster go must
be executed something that middle bear
and scammer disagree to when scama asks
everyone who's responsible for G's
defeat fleshy flesh states that a naked
man appeared out of nowhere and struck
the hero Hunter once before flying away
and that the movement was similar to
something that blast does hearing this
sweet mask and secondar are surprised to
hear that blast had got involved in the
battle Jos tells s that has the lone
right to decide how to deal with go
although saam intends to let the other
Heroes beat him up until the satisfied
zombie man approaches and asks Scarrow
about his strength Source knowing that
an earlier kadre had once spoken about
God before his Unexpected death G laughs
and claims that he alone is responsible
refusing the idea that a God could have
ever helped him as zombie man wonders if
the hero Hunter no longer has the desire
to live sweet Mark prepares to kill him
but is suddenly sought by tario who
calls out to the heroes for beating on
go explaining that he was saved by him
several times and begging for G to flee
while he still can and my takes this as
G luring a child but tiio utterly denies
this he calmly states that all of the
heroes will civilly treat go but amay
just asks him to step aside tario though
instead repeats his words saying that
they won't execute him as the heroes
argue over G's fate a powerful rumbling
suddenly travels through the air of
course it's revealed to be our man with
his King's engine running out full pump
absolutely silencing everyone bang
speaks up and states that he will not
let Geral get away with life so easily
telling him that he must make up for his
poor actions by Saving others now while
go stays quiet saarma ironically
expresses saving people as what absolute
evil is actually good at go tells
saitama he will regret letting him go
but the cape B replies that he won't
even adding his thanks to him for saving
genos and king from Platinum s and evil
natural water monster earlier while
standing there King recalls how Sait and
he spoke about how to deal with go with
the former revealing that it was go who
ended up rescuing him and Goos earlier
before Vanishing from sight though G
tells the Kate Baldi that he disgusts
him much to everyone's shock after go
leaves middle Knight suddenly appears
nearby in a giant drill and it's like
honestly stuff this dude man like he's
such a bad hero like get him out of the
organization get rid of him seeing that
the threat is over he calls in thousands
of drones in order to repair the Damage
Done to the area addressing the heroes
around middle night states that he was
lered about the nuclear fallout in the
area and announces that there will be
mandatory testing and decontamination
for all walking away with J's damaged
upper body though Sait audibly sized
depressed about how they would have to
look for the remains of the destroyed
apartment after Jos finishes getting
repaired by Dr Casino later on now enter
the police station an officer
interrogates G asking if he regrets
having dined and dashed at a restaurant
remember like way back at the beginning
of the Ark when he did that when he
doesn't answer the question and instead
talks about his beliefs bang knocks him
from behind getting him back on track
which is just hilarious I love these two
men after leaving the police station
bang tells G that he must apologize to
the victims of his hero hunt much to G's
annoyance meanwhile in a playground at a
park Terio was playing with his friends
in a game revolving around villains and
heroes randomly the group is interrupted
by wagon Mah who arrives by car with his
father ninki back to the conversation
between master and disciple G expresses
his wish to spar with the heroes he once
fought as a monster which includes
beinging G believes that by battling
them again it is possible for him to
reach some kind of Awakening without
monster rizing over at the association
headquarters sich talks to sigar going
over Bang's resignation as a hero and
desire to introduce a certain person
into the association in order to replace
them obviously that being go knowing
that the heroes will oppose go joining
them such nonetheless excepts they're
preparing for Sha's last prophecy is
Paramount which sitting here I I just
thought this now I thought this prophecy
was a thing they took over the monster
Association for in the first place they
just going to keep bringing out this
prophecy every time there's like a new
threat that they have to fight that
would be kind of funny to be honest I do
kind of like that that just blatant
reuse of the same thing just to Bringing
another threat into the universe is just
such a one punched thing but anyway
anyway anyway as the master and disciple
continues strolling around elsewhere
bang soon asks G which type of girls he
likes which is a bang of jjk line for
real although go is taken back by his
master asking such a question he
eventually answers that he fances Kido
an actress from a Super centai Show and
after a while the two began a discussion
about the current state of cintai shows
over elsewhere and they drained the
remains of the sea following the monster
Association incident sa and Jos has
seemed searching for what's left of
their apartment while I shrunk overr
Rover on the shoreline and chills out
watching
them well so that that officially brings
us to the very end of what is one punch
man's monster Association Arc and I can
say for sure that this Arc was
absolutely insane the stuff that we got
from start to finish was just phenomenal
like the art in here is out of this
freaking world so if you guys do want
more smash this video to 10K likes and
I'll begin delving into the current
stuff that's happening inside of the
story which is the Neo hero Saga and I'm
pretty sure the first Arc that we would
get into is the psychic sisters Arc so
make sure to smash that like button if
you haven't already and help push this
video to 10K likes plus subscribe if you
are new around here as well also there
were kind of a few things that I'd like
to have improved throughout just making
this video in general I really did work
hard to try and bring this entire series
to life here in this world because it's
by far like marada is probably my
favorite artist I don't know we've also
got berserk out there which is
absolutely insane in my eyes so that's
kind of hard competing with those but
it's up there and I really wanted to
make this is a special video but there
were times where say like my audio
glitched and it made a an annoying
glitch noise and then there were moments
like I when I recorded this video for
example I had my wisdom teeth were also
coming through cuz I recorded this video
like five or 6 months ago now there were
certain words that I could not pronounce
and it got me so annoyed that I just had
to stop recording for like a week at a
time and go off and do something else I
just couldn't say specific words and it
and it really got on my nerves probably
like no need for me to like explain that
now or whatever but I thought that I
should probably explain that that is the
reason why it took me so long to get it
out plus having to go through what some
of these chapters are like 150 plus
pages and then they've been reconed and
completely changed and I've had to like
rewrite an entire script it's actually
insane like the amount of times I've had
to I had to rewrite something after
writing it because I thought that was
what happened but it didn't actually
happen the thing that happened was
reconed and like Oh My My Mind melted so
many times it was actually crazy but in
the end we got there and I freaking
loved it and I hope you guys enjoyed the
video as well because the series is
phenomenal and it deserves like the
utmost respect and I really hope I could
bring it with my own like little
adaptation of the series here plus I'd
also love to know what kind of series
you guys want me to get into in the
future I just started reading kagar raki
and Sakamoto days which are two series
that are freaking phenomenal like what
is it kagar robaki at this point only
has five chapters out and that series
there is already popping off like
nothing of ever seen before so I I can't
wait till that first AR finish is there
and we might actually delve into that as
well but either way you know I'd love to
know what series you guys want me to try
and start reading or getting into but
for now let P your professional
degenerate dear Volo and I will see you
all and a BS bye